This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters,
这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。嗨，Portlandia 迷们。我是 Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen。90 年代的梦想正在以播客的形式重现。我们正在推出 Podlandia，AEO，rewatch，这是我们的全新播客，我们将一起重温 Portlandia 的每一集，剖析短剧，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，
and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch starting July 16th on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将邀请那些帮助这一切成为现实的人加入我们。特邀嘉宾、合作者和朋友，包括导演 Jonathan Chrysler、市长本人 Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家 Amy Mann 等等。Kyle 在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴创作了，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为你们都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听 Podlandia。A.O. Rewatch 从 7 月 16 日开始在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方播出。
I'm Mangishitigular, and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I talked to scientists, biopunks, cremudgeons, blues owners, super seniors, and Goa's top cryotherapy lab to try to understand this obsession with living forever and what it means for all of us. And I get into a bit of trouble along the way. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know.
我是 Mangishitigular，我带着我的播客《Skyline Drive》的新一季回来了。这一次，我采访了科学家、生物朋克、脾气暴躁的人、蓝调大咖、超级老人和果阿顶级的冷冻疗法实验室，试图理解这种对长生不老的痴迷以及这对我们所有人的意义。在这一过程中，我也遇到了一些麻烦。我想大概可以开始骨骼塑形了。那不管用。让它看起来更立体。他们说管用。我不知道。
Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is Michael Rappaport and my podcast, the I Ammer. Rapaport's stereo podcast is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to IMRAPort on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever》。我是 Michael Rappaport，我的播客是 The I Ammer。Rapaport 的立体声播客与你听过的任何人都不一样。如果你在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何引起我注意的事情的强烈观点，那么现在就订阅吧。这个名叫 Jafar Jackson 的孩子绝对应该因为他饰演 Michael Jackson 而获得提名。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 IMRAPort。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个单一的群体。
Weedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show why I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares Un-House stories and news from the Un-House perspective. Listen to Weythian House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever. you get your podcast. We've all been there. We've had seasons that have shaken everything.
Weedian House 是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是 Theo Henderson，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创作了这个节目。我们已经成长为一个两度获得威比奖的播客，也是唯一一个分享无家可归者故事和无家可归者视角新闻的播客。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Weythian House。我们都曾经历过。我们都经历过震撼一切的时期。
The question is, what remains when the shaking stops? Hi, I'm Gary Valenzheno. And on my podcast, Unshaken with Gary Vee, I sit down with amazing personalities and we talk about the seasons that nearly broke them, the lows that carried them to their highs. Listen to Unshaken with Gary Vee. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
问题是，当震撼停止时，还剩下什么？嗨，我是 Gary Valenzheno。在我的播客《Unshaken with Gary Vee》中，我与优秀的个性人物坐在一起，我们谈论那些几乎击垮他们的时期，以及将他们带向人生巅峰的低谷。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Unshaken with Gary Vee》。
Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s, there has been one special individual that we have wanted to have on the podcast for a long time, someone who has had such an interesting career trajectory and life that I think contains so many lessons for others in their 20s. She's basically lived many lives during this decade, which is a testament to her work ethic, but also, I think just our general ability
大家好。我是 Jemma Spike，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们讨论 20 多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来到这里参加另一期节目，正如我们当然要剖析 20 多岁的心理一样，有一个特别的人是我们一直很想邀请到播客上的，她有着非常有趣的职业轨迹和生活，我认为这为其他处于 20 多岁的人提供了很多经验教训。在这十年里，她基本上经历了好几段不同的人生，这证明了她的职业道德，但我也认为这只是她普遍的一种能力
to evolve time and time again. You may know her as the founder of Tala, Shredi, the productivity method or if you are an OG fan for her workout guides and plans. She is also the host of the podcast Working Hard and Oxford grad, a genuinely all-around cool person who we know and love. Grace Beverly, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thank you so much. Also, you're so good at reading. You must have loved when they came to you in class and they were like, can you read this sentence please? You did not stutter once. Well, I practice. No, I do. That's amazing. Reading comprehension. I'm going to put that up. Reading comprehension. On 10.
一次又一次地进化。你可能知道她是 Tala 的创始人，是 Shredi 生产力方法的创始人，或者如果你是老牌粉丝，就知道她是你的健身指南和计划的制定者。她也是播客《Working Hard》的主持人，牛津大学毕业生，一个我们熟知和喜爱的全面酷炫的人。Grace Beverly，欢迎来到《The Psychology of Your 20s》。非常感谢。另外，你太擅长朗读了。当他们在课堂上走到你面前说，请你能读一下这句话吗，你一定很喜欢吧？你连一次都没有结巴。嗯，我练习过。不，我确实练过。这太棒了。阅读理解。我要把它提出来。阅读理解。给满分 10 分。
When Hendwood, we were saying like before we started that when I read out the intro, you're like sitting right next week. Is it like somebody singing you happy birthday? Yeah, but then also saying like 10 nice things about you afterwards. Yeah, it never ends. Yeah, it is a lot. Okay, briefly introduce yourself. Tell us a little bit about who you are as a person and then we're going to do some ice breakers. Perfect. So I'm Grace. What am I going to say about myself? So I am an entrepreneur, I guess, is probably like the most all-encompassing way of referring to what I do. But it's, as you say, has evolved over the past decade or so.
当 Hendwood，我们在开始之前说，当我读出开场白时，你就像坐在我正旁边一样。这感觉就像有人为你唱生日快乐歌吗？是的，但随后还在你身后说了 10 件关于你的好话。是的，没完没了。是的，这确实挺多的。好吧，简单介绍一下你自己。跟我们多聊聊作为个人的你，然后我们要玩一些破冰游戏。太完美了。所以我是 Grace。我要怎么介绍我自己呢？所以我想我是一个企业家，这可能是指代我所做事情的最全面的方式。但正如你所说，在过去十年左右的时间里，它一直在演变。
So I started my first business when I was in my first term or semester. I don't know what you would call it at university. And I have since started three more businesses. And I do a lot of investing and advisory work as well on other businesses that are kind of of not in a similar space, but essentially, like my expertise is around consumer businesses and kind of how they can appeal to their customers and grow over time and all of that. So I do a lot of that work. I also have a podcast.
所以我读第一个学期或学期时开始了我的第一笔生意。我不知道你在大学里会怎么称呼它。从那以后，我又创办了另外三家企业。我还对其他一些企业做了很多投资和咨询工作，这些企业在某种程度上不在相似的领域，但本质上，我的专业知识围绕着消费类企业以及它们如何吸引客户并随着时间推移而成长等等。所以我做了很多这样的工作。我还有一个播客。
I do socials, I guess just generally showing what I am doing in my day-to-day. And my day-to-day job, I would consider the work within the businesses because that is what I do day-to-day. Sorry, by the way, if I'm very gurgly and acid refluxy, I'm afraid. There's literally nothing we can do about it. There is something inside of me. There is a giant baby. It's just like encroaching upon my esophagus.
我做社交媒体，我想通常只是展示我日常在做的事情。我日常的工作，我会认为是在企业内部的工作，因为那是我每天都在做的事情。顺便说一句，如果我的声音有很多咕噜声和胃酸倒流，我很抱歉。真的，我们对此无能为力。我体内有什么东西。有一个巨大的婴儿。它正在侵入我的食道。
And yeah, I just... The baby doesn't like the podcast. The amount of Gaviscon that's in my bag, I can't even tell you. Really? Yeah. Pop one in when you need it. When you guys hear a break, you know what we're doing. I love that way of describing you because you're a very busy woman.
是的，我只是……这个婴儿不喜欢播客。我包里的 Gaviscon（达喜）有多少，我甚至无法告诉你。真的吗？是的。需要的时候吃一片。当你们听到中场休息时，你们就知道我们在做什么了。我很喜欢你这种形容自己的方式，因为你是一个非常忙碌的女性。
And before we get into what makes you busy, we're going to do a quick little. icebreaker. We ask these kind of questions of all of our guests. Are you ready? I'm so ready. Okay. Three to one. Favorite fast food order. Okay. As you can tell, I'm really going to find out. Stop the question. Fuck. It's hard because I was veggie until quite recently. And like that's not very well, you know, catered for in fast food. So now like everything, every time I do try fast food, it's like a whole new world so I don't know if it's my go-to
在我们探讨是什么让你如此忙碌之前，我们要做一个简短的小破冰游戏。我们会向所有嘉宾提出这类问题。准备好了吗？我太准备好了。好的。三二一。最喜欢的快餐点单。好的。正如你所说，我真的要找出来。停下这个问题。操。这很难，因为直到不久前我还是素食主义者。而且快餐里对这个照顾得不是很好。所以现在一切，每当我尝试快餐时，就像是一个全新的世界，所以我不知道这算不算我的首选
you know I'm sorry no it's okay I'm really bad at being concise this one I think will be easier oh please last last thing you ordered online
你知道，我很抱歉，不，没关系。我很不擅长长话短说，这个我觉得会容易一些哦，请说说你最近在网上订购的最后一样东西
oh so I'm renovating at the moment and I have been honestly Etsy's market value has gone up by about a trillion this week based on me alone stock tip
哦，所以我现在正在装修，老实说，本周仅凭我一个人，Etsy 的市值就上涨了大约一万亿美元，股票小贴士
yeah sorry this is a stock tip you know Etsy's value Grace is on the shops. Grace is on the shops. Get investing in that. Not financial advice.
是的，抱歉，这是一个股票小贴士，你知道 Etsy 的价值，Grace 在购物。Grace 在购物。快去投资那个吧。不构成财务建议。
But I, yeah, I've been all over the trinkets. It's basically because we're so close now, I feel like I can actually start to buy the little things. I mostly want to save the little things for when you're in and you're like, oh, I could use something for that corner. But the things I've been going for generally like art, little like bookends, vintagey things I'm finding. little, I got a label, a vintage label for like the laundry room door, which I liked.
但我，是的，我一直在关注各种小饰品。基本上是因为我们现在离得很近了，我觉得我实际上可以开始购买那些小物件了。我主要想把这些小物件留到你入住之后，然后你就会想，哦，我可以用这个来装点那个角落。但我一直在寻找的东西通常是艺术品、像书挡这样的小东西、我发现的复古风格的东西。小物件，我买了一个标签，一个用于洗衣房门的复古标签，我很喜欢。
So yeah, just a hell of a lot of little trinkets. Yeah, and are you so excited every time a package comes? Or you're at this stage where you don't know what it's going to be. Well, I've ordered them to the house and I'm not currently in the house. So it's Christmas next Wednesday in case anyone does know. Okay, last sunset you saw. Oh, sunset. I went on a little girl's trip.
所以，是的，就是一大堆小饰品。是的，每次有快递来的时候你都会超级兴奋吗？还是说你已经到了这种阶段，你根本不知道里面会是什么。好吧，我把它们订到了家里，而我目前不在家。所以如果有人知道的话，下周三就是圣诞节了。好的，你见过的最后一个日落。哦，日落。我进行了一次小型女孩之旅。
few weeks ago, my girls' trip baby moon, we shall call it. It's not actually, it was for everyone, but that's how I was taking it. Last girl's trip before popping out a baby. And we saw some beautiful sunsets there,
几周前，我们的女孩之旅蜜月，我们这样称呼它。其实不是，这是大家的旅行，但这就是我的看法。生孩子前的最后一次女孩之旅。我们在那里看到了一些美丽的日落，
and it was just so lovely. It was kind of, we were in this gorgeous village where you just walk down and you just sit at a restaurant, you order some calamari, you get, everyone gets an appraisal spritz apart from me, you just have a,
真是太美妙了。这有点像，我们在这个美丽的村庄里，你只要走下去，坐在餐馆里，点一些卡拉马里鱿鱼，每个人除了我之外都点了一杯阿佩罗喷雾（Aperol Spritz），大家只是进行了一场
nice little chat and like a game of cards while the sun is setting and that is just that's where I belong. That was God's plan for us all along. Were you in Greece? Yes. Oh, delightful. Yeah. What would your friend say is your most annoying habit? Oh, where do I start? Very bad at going with the flow.
愉快的聊天，在日落时玩了一局纸牌，而这正是——这就是我属于的地方。那是上帝对我们自始至终的安排。你在希腊吗？是的。哦，太棒了。是的。你的朋友会说你最讨厌的习惯是什么？哦，我从哪里开始？非常不擅长顺其自然。
Me and the flow? Not good friends. Which is great because it does mean for every trip or whatever like you know they're like oh trip made out the group chat if i'm in the group chat if you think this isn't making out the group chat you are very much mistaken first of all second of all it unfortunately will be run as a military operation um so yeah it depends how much you like that like great because you can i guess put your feet up um but you never know what's going to happen when you open your whats up there might be 20 polls there might be a spreadsheet
我和顺其自然？不是好朋友。这很好，因为这确实意味着对于每一次旅行或其他什么，你知道的，他们会说，哦，旅行在群聊里制定好了。如果我在群聊里，如果你认为这不是在群聊里制定的，那你就大错特错了，首先，其次，不幸的是，它将作为一次军事行动来运营。嗯，所以是的，这取决于你有多喜欢这种感觉，因为你可以，我想你可以放松一下，但你永远不知道打开 WhatsApp 会发生什么，可能会有 20 个民意调查，可能会有一个电子表格
there might be a little tick box you have to fill in There might be a Google Doc. There might be a Google Doc. Yeah. It's too much. Yeah. Wait, when you and your husband go on trips, do you plan them? No.
可能会有一个你需要填写的勾选框。可能会有一个 Google 文档。可能会有一个 Google 文档。是的。太多了。等一下，你和你的丈夫去旅行时，你们会做计划吗？不。
See this. I know. I love it. I know. Guys. Sorry to post. But I, one of my favorite things about my relationship is that in the big wide world, I am like, you know, I'm feisty. I'm running around doing all my independent things.
看这个。我知道。我喜欢这样。我知道。伙计们。抱歉发文。但是，关于我的感情，我最喜欢的事情之一就是，在广阔的大千世界里，我像是个，你知道的，我很有干劲。我四处奔波，做着所有独立的事情。
When I'm at home, I am baby. when I am in that relationship, I am I baby Yeah, I baby no do things Baby feet up Baby Tommy Tickles Baby, baby get fed
当我在家里时，我是个宝宝。当我在那段关系中时，我是个宝宝。是的，我是个宝宝，不，做事情，宝宝翘起脚，宝宝挠肚子，宝宝，宝宝吃得饱饱的
free time day Baby, baby get fed well Baby don't know what airport going from What terminal, what time plane And that as someone Who is like so aggressively type A And organises every single other thing in their life Like that is, I never thought I could have that from a relationship.
自由时间日，宝宝，宝宝吃得好，宝宝不知道要从哪个机场出发，哪个航站楼，几点钟的飞机。而作为一个如此激进的 A 型人格，并且把生活中的每一件其他事情都安排得井井有条的人来说，这，我从未想过我能从一段感情中得到这个。
Because I did kind of come to terms of the fact that I was like, this is just who I am. I can't expect anyone else to have such high standards of organization because obviously you're taking it too far. But lo and behold, here he came. There he was. There he was. Flying around the corner.
因为我确实有点接受了这样一个事实，即我是这样的人。我不能指望别人也有这么高的组织标准，因为很显然你做得太过了。但看吧，他来了。他就在那儿。他就在那儿。从拐角处飞奔过来。
And now I get to be baby. Yeah, the best. Okay, two more. Texting or voice notes? I'm big on voice notes. I just think there has to be a regular cadence of them and I think that I don't know
现在我可以当个宝宝了。是的，太棒了。好的，还有两个。发短信还是发语音？我很喜欢发语音。我只是觉得它们需要有一定的规律性，而且我觉得我不知道
I think they need to serve a purpose so for example if you're going quickly back and forth in the workday is it helpful to have a voice note no because I'm in a meeting you've made it very hard for me to multitask I've got to listen to the meeting exactly and that I can't do that
我觉得它们需要有实际作用，例如，如果你在工作日快速来回沟通，发语音有帮助吗？没有，因为我在开会，你让我很难同时处理多任务，我得听会议，完全如此，而我做不到这一点
okay and a book you think everybody should read okay we were just going through some of the best books I'm having a really good reading year and I think it's only going to go from strength to strength if I'm able to read in maternity leave, which my Kindle's a good old one handhold. So I'm, you know, hoping. I just read Broken Country, which, oh my God, was so good. I honestly, so I was on my actual Baby Moon, as you can tell. I had to have multiple friends, Baby Moon and husband Baby Moon.
好的，你认为每个人都应该读的一本书。好吧，我们刚刚浏览了一些最好的书。我的阅读年过得非常好，如果我能在产假期间阅读，那将会更上一层楼，我的 Kindle 可以单手握持。所以，你知道，我抱有希望。我刚刚读了《Broken Country》，天哪，太棒了。老实说，所以我当时在真正的蜜月旅行中，正如你所见。我必须有多个朋友的蜜月和丈夫的蜜月。
When's the solo one happening? Well, yeah, this is it. it's right now. It was my trip to this office. Yeah, it was my trip to Farringen. And yeah, I just did not move all day. I was completely transfixed. It was so well written. I have quite a strict over four rule on good reads, not because I'm a snob, although you could argue, but because there are so many books out there that if I'm busy, the chances of me, like if I can just heighten the chance of me enjoying the book by it being above a four. Because I think what I used to fall into the trap of a lot is like these really overhyped books,
单人蜜月什么时候开始？好吧，是的，就是这个。就是现在。这是我去这个办公室的旅行。是的，这是我去法林顿的旅行。是的，我一整天都没动。我完全被迷住了。它写得太好了。我在 Goodreads 上有一个相当严格的四星以上规则，不是因为我是个势利小人，尽管你可能会争辩说我是，而是因为外面有太多书了，如果我很忙，我能通过选择四星以上的书来提高我喜欢这本书的概率。因为我认为我以前经常陷入的陷阱是那些被过度炒作的书籍，
they still won't be an over a four if they are badly written. Like I am so sorry to everyone, but like I really am not a Kaleen Hoover fan. And most of them are not over a four on goodreads. And therein lies the lesson. Therein lies the lesson. And I, yeah, so I generally just go for above a four and I have my whole want to read list. and then I can just filter it by the average rating. This is a mathematical affair.
如果它们写得很烂，在 Goodreads 上仍然不会超过四分。非常抱歉大家，但我真的不是 Colleen Hoover 的粉丝。而且大多数书在 Goodreads 上都没有超过四分。这就是教训所在。这就是教训所在。而且我，是的，所以我通常只选四星以上的书，我有一整张想读的书单。然后我只需按平均评分进行筛选。这是一件数学上的事情。
Yeah, I don't know why I've taken your quick-fire questions. I kind of like it. I kind of like I try to expand them into the entire podcast. But yeah, sorry for taking it so far. That's all right. You know what? I feel like we're warmed up now, though. Thank you, me too.
是的，我不知道为什么我要接受你的快问快答。我挺喜欢的。我有点喜欢，我试着把它们扩展到整个播客中。但是，是的，抱歉把它扯得太远了。没关系。你知道吗，不过我觉得我们现在已经热身了。谢谢，我也是。
We know a bit more about each other. We kind of already did. But, you know, the audience does. Let's talk about what you're here to talk about, which is business and life and work. when did you first start putting yourself out there online? Because that's kind of the beginning of this whole story, isn't it? Yeah, it absolutely is. And I think that like one of the, maybe one of the misconceptions people get about my story
我们对彼此了解更多了。其实我们本来就知道了，但是，你知道，观众们知道了。让我们谈谈你今天来要谈的事情，也就是商业、生活和工作。你是什么时候开始第一次在网上展示自己的？因为这可以说是整个故事的开始，不是吗？是的，绝对是。而且我认为，人们对我的故事可能产生的误解之一
is because it all started so long ago online. I think the assumption is that like the following was built first. And then it was like, oh, let's throw businesses on top, which totally fair. Some of them were because I obviously didn't start off all businesses at once. That would be absolutely insane. and I am a little, but like not that far. Not that far. And I started my first business and my first year at university.
是因为这一切在网上开始得很早。我认为人们的假设是，粉丝群体首先建立起来了。然后就像是，哦，让我们在上面开展业务，这完全可以理解。其中一些确实是，因为我显然没有同时创办所有的企业。那绝对太疯狂了，我有点疯狂，但还没到那种地步。没到那种地步。我在大学一年级时创办了我的第一家企业。
Well, actually, I sold my first products online within kind of six months of starting my socials. And they had just been started as like an anonymous account where I was just posting about like my fitness journey. So I was interested in staying disciplined and going to the gym. And that was not something that I had within my wheelhouse. it just wasn't something that I was capable of doing and so I started the account as I guess like an accountability thing while I was in my last year of sixth form I don't know what you would call it yeah just like the last year of like high school kind like year 12
嗯，实际上，我在开始做社交媒体大约六个月内就在网上售出了我的第一批产品。它们刚开始时就像是一个匿名账号，我只是在上面发布关于我的健身之旅的内容。所以我对保持自律和去健身房很感兴趣。这并不是我擅长的领域，这根本不是我能够做到的事情，所以我开始这个账号，我想就像是一个监督机制，当时我在读高中的最后一年，我不知道你们会怎么称呼它，是的，就像是高中最后一年，有点像 12 年级
not if you like it's the two years after if you left at 16 so like the 18 one yeah yeah um and I yeah I just started up the account as I said it was anonymous I didn't show my face all of that um started and then started selling products on there a few months later. And then by the time I actually went to start what I consider now, like my first business, I was about a year later. And I guess I just had like a year experimenting with the, because the first products I sold were digital ebugs and, or just ebugs. They are digital. And essentially, I guess I'd kind of played around with that, that year being like, oh, okay, well, if I put it 20% off or like a flash sale then more people come in or I put it like a bundle deal and people buy
如果你 16 岁离开，那就是接下来的两年，所以像 18 岁那个，是的，是的，嗯，我，是的，我刚开始做这个账号，正如我所说，它是匿名的，我没有露脸，诸如此类，开始了，几个月后开始在上面销售产品。然后等我真正开始我现在认为的我的第一笔生意时，大约是一年之后。我想我只是花了一年时间来试验，因为我卖的第一批产品是数字电子书，或者只是电子书。它们是数字化的。本质上，我想我在那一年里尝试过，比如，哦，好吧，如果我降价 20% 或者搞个限时抢购，那么就会有更多的人来，或者我搞一个捆绑销售，人们就会买
you know people are more likely to buy two than one or like you know you do a limited thing whatever so I kind of like come to terms with how some of these things work and so then by the time I started the business like a year later I kind of realized that that was a viable option and by that point I'd gone from having like one or two thousand followers to having I think around 100,000. That's crazy. Yeah. And so that's when I started that.
你知道，人们买两件的可能性比买一件大，或者你知道，你做一个限量的东西，无论如何，所以我有点弄懂了其中一些事情是如何运作的，所以当我一年后开始创业时，我有点意识到这是一个可行的选择，到那个时候，我已经从拥有一两千粉丝发展到拥有大约 10 万粉丝。这太疯狂了。是的。所以这就是我开始的时候。
Okay, this brings me to some follow-up questions. Did you show your face first or did somebody realize it was you first? Oh, they realized it was me. Yeah. Was it like, which is so I kind of showed my face out of like, well. Here I am. There we go. Games up.
好的，这让我想到了几个后续问题。是你先露脸的，还是有人先发现那是你？哦，他们发现是我了。是的。是这样的，我露脸有点像是，好吧。我来了。就这样。游戏结束了。
And who was it? Do you remember? Oh, yeah. There was a lot of Chad school. And I think also because I was, so I'd only joined that school a year before. So I wasn't, it was a school, obviously like with high school, like people had been there since they were like 11. I had not. And so I was already kind of like new girly.
那是谁？你记得吗？哦，是的。学校里有很多八卦。而且我想也是因为我，所以我只加入那所学校一年。所以我不，这是一所学校，很明显就像高中一样，人们从 11 岁起就在那里了。我没有。所以当时我已经是那种新来的女孩了。
And then just, yeah, word got around. And I remember coming back to school after because it was like after the Easter holidays. And I'd been like, you know, doing my posting and all of this. And then I just remember coming back in and being like, I hear whispers. It's like gossip girl. to the gossip girl real life fantasy. And it was very like what the fuck because I think that now
然后，是的，消息就传开了。我记得复活节假期后回到学校，因为就像在复活节假期之后。我一直在，你知道的，发帖和做这些事情。然后我只记得走进来然后想，我听到流言蜚语了。这就像《绯闻女孩》。走进了《绯闻女孩》的现实生活幻想中。这感觉非常像他妈的怎么回事，因为我认为现在
even at the time people not everyone had personal Instagrams like it wasn't really like we were on Facebook like people didn't have personal internet well a few people did but it wasn't like you'd be posting the toast you just buttered like it wouldn't be like this is me it's like a sepia filter
甚至在当时，也不是每个人都有个人 Instagram账号，当时我们其实都在用 Facebook，人们没有个人网络——嗯，少数人有，但它不像现在这样，你会发布刚刚抹了黄油吐司的照片，不会像是这就是我，它是一个怀旧滤镜
yeah like as in unlikely to even be a selfie like come on and pull yourself together whereas there was me being like don't want to the gym today here's a salad you know. Yeah. So it just wasn't that well regarded, I would say. That sucks. But you made, I feel like you got the opportunity to basically have like a playground to understand business on your own. A hundred percent, very low risk as well. I always, I think that there's like a lot of narrative online around like,
是的，就像甚至不太可能是一张自拍照一样，得了吧，振作点吧，而当时的我却在想，今天不想去健身房，这是沙拉，你知道的。是的。所以它并没有受到太多的赞赏，我想说。太糟糕了。但你做到了，我觉得你得到了一个机会，基本上拥有了一个可以让你自己摸索商业的游乐园。百分之百，风险也很低。我一直认为，网上有很多关于
take the leap, quit your job, do this. And it's like, I was very fortunate to be in the position where I never needed to do that. Because A, I started with digital products, which have basically zero sunk cost. like you don't really need to pay a lot to get into them. You just need to do the work on it. And like I paid 50 quid to a friend who was a graphic design student to like make them look nice. Before Canva. Before Canva. Pre-Canver in the world PC.
迈出这一步，辞掉工作，做这个的言论。而我觉得，我很幸运能够处于这样一个位置，我从来不需要这样做。因为 A，我从数字产品开始，这些产品的沉没成本基本为零，你真的不需要花很多钱就能进入这个领域。你只需要在上面做工作。就像我付了 50 英镑给一个学平面设计的朋友，让他们把产品做得很漂亮。在 Canva 出现之前。在 Canva 出现之前的 PC 时代。
And essentially that was, yeah, because I was like, it's an e-book. It needs to look nice. But other than that, like there's no marginal cost. So if two people bought it, it's cost me the same to produce as like one. So like every extra thing you sell is just cash. And so, yeah, it was like I never needed it. And then also I went on to university. Like, I've never been full time.
本质上，这就是，是的，因为我想，这是一本电子书。它需要看起来不错。但除此之外，没有边际成本。所以如果有两个人买它，它的生产成本和一个人买是一样的。所以你卖出的每一件额外的东西都是纯现金。所以，是的，就像我从来不需要它。然后我还上了大学。就像，我从来没有全职做过。
There was never a moment where I had to be like full time in the business. Yeah. Before they'd actually, you know, I then had three years of university to really like work it out. Yeah. That's crazy. And you went and studied music. Yeah. Which I think a lot of people may not know.
从来没有哪个时刻我必须全职投入到业务中。是的。在他们实际，你知道的，我接着有三年的大学时间来真正弄清楚它。是的。这太疯狂了。你还去学了音乐。是的。我想很多人可能不知道这一点。
Maybe. And what was it was like, I was doing some digging on the Wikipedia page. Oh, yeah, you got some digging on the thing. I was like, I got it. That's what she's for. I hope you did the nice donation link to Wikipedia. Yeah, I always do. I always feel bad.
也许吧。我在维基百科页面上做了一些挖掘。哦，是的，你在上面做了一些挖掘。我当时就想，我找到了。这就是她擅长的。我希望你给维基百科捐了款。是的，我总是捐。我总是觉得很内疚。
They're always like, we're begging you. Yeah, yeah. We will chat down tomorrow. And I'm like, donate two cents. I'm like, oh, be rude not to. I always do it. But what do you think about studying music and like the arts helped you with business? Oh, I don't know if that much.
他们总是说，我们在求求你。是的，是的。我们明天就要关门了。而我心想，捐两分钱吧。我想，哦，不捐就太粗鲁了。我总是捐。但是你觉得学习音乐和艺术对你的商业有什么帮助？哦，我不知道有没有那么大帮助。
I think that the main, okay, main things I think I really learned from. the like music background. Worth saying as well that my degree was specific, it was all essay-based, so it wasn't actually like performance-based. I imagine you having to sing like for your exams. Okay, time of me, yeah, exactly. Time for you'll sing so, maybe.
我认为主要的，好吧，我从音乐背景中真正学到的主要事情。值得一提的是，我的学位很具体，全部都是基于论文的，所以实际上并不是基于表演的。我能想象你在考试时不得不唱歌。好吧，到我了，是的，正好。是时候让你唱歌了，也许吧。
And that's an A. Thank you. But no, it was all essay-based. So it was like the areas I specialized in were like politics and philosophy of music. So music's used in like during censorship eras or like whatever. Anyway, so I think that the two main things that it taught me were, one, it was a very, because of the university I went to, it was a very high workload course. So essentially it was, I had like 10,000 words a week for three years. And then none of that counted. Well, it counted in that if you didn't do it, you were getting kicked out. But it didn't count towards your grade until the last month. Oh my God. Yeah. And you were consistently examined, but not for. for like your place rather than...
那就是 A。谢谢。但不是的，全都是基于论文的。所以我专攻的领域是音乐政治学和哲学。比如音乐如何在审查时代被使用，或者其他什么。总之，我认为它教给我的两件主要事情是，第一，由于我去的大学，这是一门工作量非常大的课程。所以本质上是，我连续三年每周要写 10,000 字。而且这些都不算数。好吧，算数的地方在于如果你不写，你就会被开除。但直到最后一个月，它才计入你的成绩。天哪。是的。你一直在接受考核，但不是为了
So you can stay here, not even for like your grade. Exactly. And so then it's all like culminates in this big horror. And then the other thing I think that music and that musical background I guess really taught me was like, I think you face so much rejection doing music and the arts generally. Like there will always be people who are far better than you, like always. And you have to work so hard and put in so many extra hours and it's not very well. It definitely wasn't where I was like. considered like cool or prestigious or reputable or like whatever it might be. And you did that at the
你的名额，而是为了……所以你能留在这里，甚至不是为了你的成绩。完全正确。然后这一切都在这个巨大的恐怖中达到高潮。然后我认为音乐和这种音乐背景真正教给我的另一件事是，我觉得你在从事音乐和艺术时会面临那么多的拒绝。总是会有人比你强得多，总是这样。你必须付出极其艰辛的努力，投入如此多的额外时间，而且它并不是很好。它绝对不像是我觉得
same time and like had to spend so many hours outside of school and university like doing the extra. And then you were just constantly shut down, shut down like the entire time. So it teaches you to have a very good relationship with rejection because literally just constantly like I don't remember a, like this is not due to be a self story. But like as in like I don't remember a single time where like, well, there were probably like two, three times total where I went for something and actually got it. And it was, you know, the thing I'd really work for most of the rest of the time. Like you do a fuckload of, am I allowed to swear?
被认为是酷、声望高、有名望或者其他什么的地方。你同时做这件事，并且不得不在学校和大学之外花那么多时间去做额外的事。然后你却不断地被拒绝，整个过程都在被拒绝。所以它教会了你与拒绝建立非常好的关系，因为字面意思就是不断地——这不是一个自我故事。但是，正如——我不记得有哪个，这并不是一个自吹自擂的故事。但就像——我不记得有哪一次，好吧，总共大概只有两三次，我争取了某样东西并且真的得到了。而且那是，你知道的，我为之付出了大部分精力的东西。其余的大多数时候。就像你做了大量的工作——我能说脏话吗？
Yeah. Well, thank you. Thank you. I feel like I can do it for England. Exactly. I'm really good at those. Like, essentially where you do a fuckload of work and then you don't get anything for it.
可以。好吧，谢谢。谢谢。我觉得我可以为英国说脏话了。没错。我真的很擅长那些。基本上就是你做了大量的工作，然后什么也得不到。
And in fact, you're kind of shot down and they're like, you know, the rest of your life. They're not going to be like, oh, you're really bad at this. But like, you're kind of being consistently told. like other people are better than you. And I think because I did that from so early, like I worked at a cathedral from when I was eight, which essentially was like like 20 or so hours on top of schoolwork every week of music.
事实上，你有点被贬低了，他们会说，你知道的，你的余生。他们不会直接说，哦，你真的很糟糕。但就像，你一直在被告知
And then like from that point onwards, it's like it's actually just like a, I think the main thing it taught me is just like a crash course in being happy with rejection or just like being okay. And being able to work really, really hard and then get nothing shut down over and over again. which is huge in business and huge in entertainment.
其他人比你更好。而且我认为因为我很早就经历了这一切，我从八岁起就在大教堂工作，那基本上是每周在学校功课之外还要进行大约 20 小时或更多的音乐练习。
A hundred percent. And just like, I think a very good life skill. Like you have, we see all of that, you know, TikTok stuff, for example, on like rejection exposure therapy. And I think actually I saw it a lot. Like I, where you come across people who maybe haven't had as much rejection and therefore the rejection they do have really, really shuts them down. And that's a totally natural reaction. But actually, if you're consistently, like, even now, there have been so many things that, I mean, you know, obviously it wouldn't be public,
然后从那个时间点开始，实际上就像是一个，我认为它教给我的主要事情就是如何快速适应并对拒绝感到高兴，或者只是感觉没问题。并且能够非常非常努力地工作，然后一次又一次地一无所获、遭到拒绝。这在商业和娱乐界都是巨大的资产。
but like so many things that I've interviewed for or tried out for, like, whatever it might be, that I would really want. And it's like, if it just comes through and it's a rejection, it's like, oh. Yeah, great. Next. Yeah, exactly. I've been doing this recently where I've been like emailing, emailing guests that I really want. And they are ridiculous guests, ridiculous.
百分之百。而且就像，我认为这是一项非常好的生活技能。我们看到了所有那些 TikTok 上的内容，例如关于拒绝暴露疗法的。我实际上看到过很多次。比如我，你遇到一些人，他们可能没有经历过那么多的拒绝，因此他们所经历的拒绝真的会彻底击垮他们。这是一个完全自然的反应。但实际上，如果你不断地，就像即使现在，也有很多事情，我的意思是，你知道的，当然不会是公开的
But I'm like, otherwise the answer is no. Yeah, so let's go for it. There's 100% of the shots you don't take And I will say the other week I was like Simone Biles' assistant said no and she actually emailed me back And I was like that's a win Yeah exactly
但就像有很多我面试过或尝试过的事情，无论是什么，我真的很想要。如果结果出来是个拒绝，就会觉得，哦。太棒了。下一个。是的，正好。我最近一直在这样做，比如发邮件，给那些我真正想要的嘉宾发邮件。他们都是非常了不起的嘉宾，非常了不起。
It was like an email back was a win And I genuinely was like Throughout all this rejection Like the fact that I've gotten through And somebody's even maybe she didn't My favourite is when they come back with something That like it's actually unnecessary colour On top of the rejection
但我心想，否则答案就是“不”。所以让我们去争取吧。百分之百不尝试的球永远不会进。而且我不得不说，上周我心想，西蒙·拜尔斯的助理说“不”，但她实际上给我回了邮件，我当时想，这是一场胜利，是的，正好
It's like oh yeah yeah we really don't like This type of thing We don't like Oh okay but we're not prioritising this kind of exposure Right now. Actually, we just don't like you. Your podcast at all. She's actually got really, not to run bars, but like, she actually has really terrible
回信本身就是一场胜利。我真的觉得，在经历所有这些拒绝的过程中，事实证明我坚持了下来，甚至有人——也许她没有，我最喜欢的是他们回信时带有一些
experience of you and, yeah. But it was really nice. They sent me this lovely email and I was like, that is the biggest win. A direct no was the biggest win. And I was like, this is great for my character. And I think that like for anyone who maybe knows that that is an area that they haven't got enough exposure to, like purposefully putting yourself in that track, I think is one of the best things you can do because until you're used to rejection, you're going to
实际上是不必要的、带有嘲讽意味的色彩，并在拒绝之上加了一句
continuously be scared of it and also probably have an underlying fear of even going for things where you think you might be rejected, whereas like we know that like the surface area of luck thing, for example, is all around like putting yourself in positions where you could get lucky, like not that way. Yeah. But like, what are you got? You could do that too. But like essentially where like we've said it, like you miss 100% of the shots you don't take. So if you're not putting it, yourself in those environments. You don't know whether yeah, they wanted someone with these 10 qualifications and you only have three
就像，哦，是的，是的，我们真的很不喜欢这种类型的事情，我们不喜欢，哦，好吧，但我们现在不优先考虑这种曝光。实际上，我们只是不喜欢你。根本不喜欢你的播客。她实际上有很糟糕的——不是要贬低谁，但就像，她实际上对你有非常糟糕的
but actually they decided you were better at these other things. And like you never would have known if you hadn't put yourself there and if you're scared of rejection that's going to be very hard. Yeah, it's a huge thing to learn. Listen, and you're there for heart-wrenching
经历，并且，是的。但这真的很不错。他们给我发了一封很可爱的邮件，我心想，这才是最大的胜利。直接的拒绝就是最大的胜利。我心想，这太棒了，对我的性格很有帮助。而且我认为，对于任何可能知道自己在这一领域接触不够的人来说，刻意让自己走上这条轨道，我认为这是你能做的最好的事情之一，因为直到你习惯了拒绝，你就会
knockouts. The world's biggest stage. And breathtaking triumph. In 2020, 2006, FIFA World Cup. The knockout stage. Every match, every moment. Listen on TSN Radio. Join the globe. On the road to the July 19th final.
一直对它感到恐惧，并且可能对去争取那些你认为自己可能会被拒绝的事情有一种潜在的恐惧，而我们知道，比如“幸运的表面积”这个概念，完全是关于把自己放在可能走运的位置上，不是那种方式。是的。但是，你能做什么呢？你也可以那样做。但基本上，正如我们所说，你错过了 100% 你没有尝试的投篮。所以如果你没有把自己放在那些环境中。你就不会知道，是的，他们想要一个具备这 10 个资格的人，而你只有 3 个
2026 FIFA World Cup. Stream it all live on TSN Radio. Available on IHeart Radio. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports,
但实际上他们认为你在其他方面更好。如果你害怕拒绝，你永远不会知道这一点，而且这将是非常困难的。是的，这是一个需要学习的巨大课题。听着，你要去经历那些令人心碎的
a new podcast from Together and IHeart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about. these days. The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments to take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. We'll give you our tapes, our debates, and probably a few disagreements. We'll talk to athletes, celebrate big moments and get into what's happening on and off the field, sport, track, and beyond. Because we're
淘汰赛。世界最大的舞台。以及令人屏息的胜利。2020 年，2006 年，国际足联世界杯。淘汰赛阶段。每一场比赛，每一个时刻。在 TSN Radio 上收听。加入全球。在通往 7 月 19 日决赛的道路上。
not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. So if you're already a fan, you're just getting into the game, there's a seat for you right here. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
2026 年国际足联世界杯。在 TSN Radio 上直播所有精彩内容。可在 iHeart Radio 上收看。最近怎么样，家人们？我是体育记者 Ari Chambers。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？我是 Sam J，我们是《Everyone Watches Women's Sports》的主持人，
I'm Munga shit together, and I'm back with a new season of the podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones, and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about. And what it really means to live, forever for all of us.
这是来自 Together 和 iHeart Women's Sports 的全新播客。因为说实话。如今女子体育给我们提供了太多谈资。精彩集锦、竞争对决、新星崛起、占领你整个时间线的时刻。以及在比赛期间开始并不知为何持续了一整周的对话。每周我们都在剖析女子体育中的重大故事。我们将分享我们的录像带分析、辩论，可能还有一些分歧。我们将与运动员交谈，庆祝重大时刻，并深入探讨场上场下、运动场、赛道及其他地方正在发生的事情，因为我们
I learned about some rad science. I can make a brain for you, and then we can test what draw is the best for your brain, as opposed to his brain. Here's some hard truths. I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four to five-year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble. I'd say probably start bone smashing.
不仅仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在关注女子体育。所以无论你已经是球迷，还是刚刚开始接触这项运动，这里都有你的座位。收听《Everyone Watches Women's Sports》。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。
That doesn't work. To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of the unhoused,
我是 Munga shit together，我带着播客《Skyline Drive》的新一季回来了。这一次，我深入研究了肽、类器官、年轻血液、蓝色区域和大脑置换的兔子洞，试图理解这种对长寿的痴迷究竟是怎么回事。以及对我们所有人来说，长生不老究竟意味着什么。
stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The UnHouse is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host. and for years I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. We'd be in house is a two-time webby and signal award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Wichler,
我了解了一些很酷炫的科学。我可以为你制造一个大脑，然后我们可以测试哪种药丸最适合你的大脑，而不是他的大脑。以下是一些残酷的真相。我本以为印度人会老得更快，但我没想到加速会达到将近四到五年。并且让自己陷入了一堆麻烦中。我想大概可以开始骨骼塑形了。
a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Weythian House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rapaport Stereo Podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard.
那不管用。让它看起来更立体。他们说管用。我不知道。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Skyline Drive How to Live Forever》。主流媒体充满了对无家可归者的残酷描绘，
We're a variety show, and if you're looking for strong opinions, funny opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid, Jafar Jackson, is as good as Rami Malik as Freddie Mercury, and it's as good as Timothy Shamaulay as Bob Dylan. And I say that with love and respect for both of those actors. And I don't know how many Oscar nominations they give out, I don't know if it's five, six for best actor. 150% this kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我们是一个综合娱乐节目，如果你想听关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何能吸引我眼球的事物的犀利观点、有趣见解，现在就订阅吧。这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的小伙子，演迈克尔·杰克逊就像雷米·马利克演弗雷迪·墨古尔一样出色，也跟蒂莫西·柴勒梅德演鲍勃·迪伦一样精彩。我对这两位演员都充满爱与敬意。我不知道他们颁发多少个奥斯卡提名，我不知道是不是五、六个最佳男主角提名。150%可以肯定，这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的小伙子绝对应该因他饰演的迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。在Iheart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听I Am Rap Report。
Speaking of something that wasn't a rejection, maybe, but I think was a great success. When did you get the idea Fatala? And where did the name come from? Oh yeah, I can tell you. It was a very boring story. Sorry. I'll try it was throw it out. Let's go. So yeah, I started Tyler in my final year at university. Actually, before that, like the month before that month I told you about where everything counts towards your degree. So that was really smart. Why? Did you do that? Well, because it was meant to. Yeah, exactly. I love it. Suffering, kink. No, it was meant to essentially launch a good while before then. It just kept getting pushed for a number of different reasons, like manufacturing delays, a number of these different things. And then I was just like, we just have to get it out because I'm paying people.
说到那个可能不算拒绝、但我认为是巨大成功的事情。你是什么时候有了创立Tala的想法？这个名字又是从哪里来的？哦，是的，我可以告诉你。这是一个非常无聊的故事。抱歉。我会试着把它抛开。我们开始吧。所以，是的，我在大学最后一年创立了Tala。实际上，在那之前，就在我跟你说过的那种一切都算作学位成绩的前一个月。所以这真的很聪明。为什么？你要这么做？嗯，因为本来就该如此。对，完全正确。我喜欢。受虐倾向吗？不，它本来应该在那之前很久就正式推出。只是因为各种不同的原因一推再推，比如生产延误、各种各样的事情。然后我当时就觉得，我们必须把它推向市场，因为我在付给大家工资。
and we just, we need to launch, basically, and it just happened to fall at the worst possible time. But, rewining back, I got the idea for the business about a year before, I guess, like, I was very much, like, within the space. Like, I was wearing a lot of active wear. I was, I was a student, and I went to the gym. So, like, obviously, I was wearing active wear most at the time. And I had really strong opinions on, like, how things fit and how things felt. And I felt like a lot of, I felt like a lot of designs were.
我们必须得推出新品了，基本上就是这样，而它偏偏赶在最糟糕的时期推出了。不过，回过头来看，我大约在一年前就有了这个创业想法，当时我非常深耕这个领域。比如，我经常穿运动休闲装。我当时是个学生，而且我去健身房。所以，很明显，我大部分时间都穿着运动休闲装。我对服装的剪合度和穿着感有着非常强烈的看法。我觉得很多，我觉得很多设计在
within the industry, we're either like super revealing, which actually I don't find that flattering on me. We do, you know, gorgeous, like, strappy bras and like all of that. And they look amazing. But I think that, like, I, it felt like it either needed to be teeny tiny or it needed to be kind of frumpy. And I wasn't, I was like, actually, that's not where I like to kind of sit in terms of the designs I go for. But also, one of the main things was that I'd moved away from fast fashion consumption in my day to day life. So I just wasn't, I wasn't like, I don't know, I used to, terrible, but I used to like have contracts with like PLT and a number of different fast fashion houses and all of that. Like with my fast fashion houses was really like blowing them
这个行业里，要么超级暴露，其实我并不觉得这很显身材。你知道的，那些华丽的带吊带的胸衣之类的。它们看起来棒极了。但我认为，我当时觉得它要么得做成极小号的，要么就得显得土里土气。而我并不是那种风格，我觉得，其实这并不是我所追求的设计风格。而且，还有一个主要原因，就是我的日常生活已经不再消费快时尚了。所以我不再像以前那样，我不知道，我以前的做法很糟糕，但我以前跟PLT以及一些不同的快时尚品牌签有合同，诸如此类的。我跟那些快时尚品牌的合作，真的是把它们
up in the LVMH like direction. But yeah, yeah, the houses. Yeah. And they're runways. Yeah, exactly. But I had essentially had contracts with them and that was a big part of my job. And I literally stopped that overnight. Like I canceled on my contracts. I lost like 75% of my income because I was just like, this is not something I want to stand by. I really don't like it. I feel shit every time I post about it. And then I kind of moved away from it in my day-to-day, like, actual consumption. And I just realized that activeware was like a glaringly big gap in that way because you don't, because you think of it as like a necessity for the thing you're doing.
往LVMH那样的方向去推动。但没错，没错，那些品牌。是的。还有它们的时装秀。是的，完全如此。但基本上我之前跟它们有合同，那是我的工作很大的一部分。而我几乎是一夜之间就停掉了这些合作。我取消了合同，损失了大约75%的收入，因为我当时觉得，这不是我想支持的事物。我真的很不喜欢它。每次发布相关内容我都觉得很恶心。后来我在日常生活中也逐渐不再接触这些了。我突然意识到，运动休闲装在这方面是一个极其明显的巨大空白，因为你不会，因为你会把它当作你正在做的事情的必需品。
You kind of look less at it being like a cherry on top. And therefore you're like, oh, I'm not really thinking about the materials or who's made it or any of that. And so I had realized that I've moved away from that my day to day, but not necessarily my active wear. And then the biggest solutions that I was finding for my day to day, which were things like rental and pre-owned and like amazing ethical brands, all of this, were either not really available in activeware for reasons like pre-owned and rental. People aren't as keen on for activeware. They do exist, but like, you know, you probably, well, you probably, like, that's the thing. Like there are solutions for it, but it's probably not going to reach a mass market change level. No. And then also with the ethical brands, there were some brands that had done some really amazing things.
你不太会把它看作是锦上添花的东西。因此你会想，哦，我其实根本不会去考虑面料是什么、是谁制作的，或者诸如此类的东西。所以我意识到我在日常生活中已经不再接触这些了，但在运动休闲装方面却不一定。然后我在日常生活中能找到的最佳解决方案，比如租赁、二手以及那些出色的道德时尚品牌，所有这些，在运动休闲装领域要么并不真正适用，因为像二手和租赁这样的模式。人们对运动休闲装的兴趣没那么高。它们确实存在，但你知道的，你大概，好吧，你大概，就是这样。虽然有解决方案，但它可能无法达到大众市场变革的水平。没有。而且关于道德品牌，确实有一些品牌做了一些非常了不起的事情。
But again, they were like, they were probably about 50% more price-wise. And so I wanted to look into creating an option that was granted, like not about being small and artisanal. It was kind of, can we do better at scale? So like, can we have some baseline assumption? in terms of like what we are and aren't going to do in terms of fabrics, in terms of factories, in terms of dying processes, in terms of sampling, in terms of packaging, in terms of all of these different things. Because I think people think of, you know, those types of things in terms of just materials,
但同样地，它们在价格上可能要贵出50%左右。所以我想探索创造一个这样的选择，当然，它不是关于走小众手工作坊路线的。它更像是，我们能否在规模化生产中做得更好？比如，我们在面料、工厂、染色流程、样品制作、包装以及所有这些不同的事情上，能否有一些基本的底线标准和承诺？因为我认为人们在看待这些事情时，往往只想到材料本身。
whereas it's actually so much more behind the scenes like 0% to landfill pledges, not restocking during sales and therefore just, you know, trying to sell loads and loads of stuff at sale price, like all of that. And so we kind of, I wanted to create an active web brand that ticked those. boxes and also was like you wouldn't see a difference in terms of like fit. Yeah. And it wasn't 50% more expensive. So it took a long time because that's quite hard. And I think that, you know, there are a lot of ideals around what you would want from lots of brands you shop from. I think realistically, a lot of the time they haven't been done for a reason because it's like
而实际上幕后还有很多很多工作，比如“零填埋”承诺、在促销期间不补货因此也就不会试图通过促销价卖出成吨的东西，等等。所以我们当时，我想创建一个符合这些标准的运动休闲服装品牌，同时你也不会觉得它在剪裁上有什么不同。是的。而且它不会贵上50%。所以这花了很长时间，因为这相当难。而且我认为，关于你从常买的许多品牌中想要什么，存在着很多理想化的想法。我觉得现实中，很多时候这些理想没有被实现是有原因的，因为这
not maintainable. But we, yeah, I kind of got to starting that about a year before it ended up launching and then launched that, as I said, in May of 2019. And now we're here. Seven years later. That's crazy. And she's thriving. She is thriving. I was there the other day.
根本无法持续。但我们，是的，我大约在品牌最终推出前的一年开始筹备，然后正如我所说，在2019年5月将其推出了。现在我们就在这里了。七年过去了。太疯狂了。而且它现在发展得风生水起。确实风生水起。我前几天还在那儿呢。
Oh, were you? Yeah, when you were in Australia, I sent you a message. Oh, yeah, yeah. I was like, checking up on your first baby. Well, thank you. They was, you know, your top members are really nice. Everyone's love. Yeah, she was, I want to give her a shout out.
哦，是吗？对，当你在澳大利亚的时候，我给你发了条信息。哦，对，对。我当时在想，去看看你的第一个“孩子”。好吧，谢谢你。她们真的，你知道，你们的高级店员人真的很好。大家都很有爱。对，她，我想给她大声点赞。
She had red hair. That's all I remember. Oh, was it at the Carnaby Street store or the Westfield one? The one in Carnegie Street. She was delight. There you go. Everyone's amazing. Yeah.
她有一头红发。我只记得这个了。哦，那是卡纳比街的店还是韦斯特菲尔德的那家？卡纳比街的那家。她太讨人喜欢了。你看吧。每个人都太棒了。是的。
So sweet. Again, I mean, like, obviously is separate. But like we, with the store expansion, for example, it was like, how do we create an in-person environment that reflects are online and kind of like who we are in HQ and all of that? Like really feels in that way rather than just being like, yeah, we'll just hire these people in as quickly as possible. It was like, no, it's like we're like a, you know, we're like a girl's girl brand. We know how we want you to feel in the clothes. We know how we want you to feel in the shop. So, like, we've got to represent that in the physical space.
太贴心了。再说一次，我的意思是，很显然，实体店是另一回事。但我们在进行门店扩张时，比如，我们就在想：如何创造一个能反映我们线上形象、我们在总部时的核心理念以及我们是谁的线下实体环境？让它真正体现出那种感觉，而不是仅仅敷衍了事，觉得“好吧，我们赶紧随便招些人来就行了”。我们觉得不行，因为我们是一个（你知道的）非常注重女性社群的品牌。我们深知希望你穿着这些衣服时有怎样的感受，也知道希望你在店里时有怎样的体验。所以，我们必须在实体空间中呈现出这种感觉。
Other thing I liked about the Tala store, and then we'll move on. There's a right now. Let's just do a whole podcast on this. I really liked that, like, you guys had all the sizes out. I was like, oh, thank God. Yeah. And a big conscious decision. Oh, great.
关于Tala的店，我喜欢另外一点，我们接下来再讨论。现在正聊着呢。干脆就专门为这做一个完整的播客吧。我真的很喜欢，你们把所有的尺码都直接摆出来了。我当时就想：哦，谢天谢地。是的，这是一个非常刻意的决定。哦，太棒了。
I was like, this is amazing because I hate when you go to a store. It's like, so do you have, what's the biggest size you have? Yeah. can you get it for me? And it's like, it just kind of always sucks. Yeah. I don't know. It's not a good feeling. Yeah, of course. And like, you know, there have been lots of, I would say, like, learning curves. Because again, it's like you go from running like what's an online store where everything is in one warehouse. It is getting shipped out from one place. And so everything's in one place to even like everything new you launch, needing it to get to one store. But you also need like the exact right size ratio. You don't know who's going to come in that day. And like,
我当时觉得这太棒了，因为我讨厌你去实体店的时候。店员会问：“请问你们最大的尺码是什么？”对。“你能帮我找一下吗？”感觉这种体验总是糟透了。对。我不知道。这种感觉真不好。对，当然。而且，你知道，我也经历过许多，可以说，学习曲线。因为同样地，你从经营一个所有商品都在一个仓库里的在线商店，所有货物都从一个地方发货，所以一切都在一个地方；转变到你推出的每一款新新品，都需要送到某一家实体店。但你还需要精确的尺码比例。你根本不知道那天会有谁来。而且，
knowing that you need, like you can estimate it, but like how many of those pieces do you actually need in the store across how many sizes, different colors, like all of this. Like it's, you know, I'm sure we won't have got it right for everyone. But it's a, it's been a massive, like, learning curve and I'm very proud of, like, the reviews and kind of love we get from how people feel when they're in there and that. Let's take it down. Let's take a turn for the worst. Yeah, no more compliments. Yeah. No more good stuff you're doing for the environment, women's self-confidence.
你知道你需要，虽然你可以做个估算，但这些单品到底需要在店里备多少库存，涵盖多少种尺码和不同的颜色，等等。这，你知道的，我确信我们不可能做到让所有人都满意。但这确实是一个巨大的学习曲线，我为我们收到的评价以及大家在店里时感受到的那种喜爱之情感到非常自豪。让我们转换一下话题。让我们转向糟糕的一面吧。好的，不再有赞美了。对，不再夸奖你为环保和女性自信所做的好事了。
What's been the biggest, like, oh, fuck. moment of running a business. Oh, there have been so many. They are every day. They are relentless. No, I think, I mean, I actually do think that, like, that is one of the most defining parts of having a business is, like, you are constantly just, like, on the floor. Which is like, why?
经营一家企业最让人觉得“操蛋”的时刻是什么时候？哦，有太多了。它们每天都在发生。简直没完没了。不，我觉得，其实我认为，这正是拥有自己公司最具标志性的部分之一，那就是你总是被整得趴在地上。这也就是为什么，会
Like, more and more of this. Like, my propensity to deal with stress now, I think is so high. Actually, for the bad reason of the fact that, like, shit is thrown at me every single day. Like, big, big stuff. you know and I think that's just part of having a business and then you add in more businesses it's kind of like just increases the cadence of these types of things coming up um there are many different ones like there have been big oh fuck ones like in like 2020 2021 tarla very nearly went by by um and that was like a good year long battle like to and within that like I can't remember how long it
经历越来越多这种时刻？我现在处理压力的能力，我觉得变得非常高。当然，这是一个不好的原因导致的，那就是每天都有各种狗屁倒灶的事朝我砸来。而且都是大事，你知道的。我认为这就是经营企业的一部分，当你拥有更多企业时，这种事情发生的频率就会相应增加。有很多不同的时刻，比如有些重大的“操蛋”时刻发生在2020年到2021年，当时Tala差点就彻底完蛋了。那是一场长达整整一年的艰难拉锯战。在那个过程中，我不记得具体持续了多长时间，但大概有两个月的时间
would have been, but it would have been like around two months of like working out whether we're going to make payroll every single week and being like, that would be the most stressful part I can imagine being like, it's okay if I go bankrupt. Yeah. Well, it had times when I was literally like, I would pay salaries out of like my Monso account. Like as in like, you know, I had like one payroll that we weren't going to make and I was like, fuck. And I sold my car the next day to like someone I found online, which was literally like a, what was it? It was like a, they'd come to your house and they just buy your car for you. And I was like, I don't even know if this is legit.
我都在苦苦计算我们每周到底能不能支付得起员工的工资，并且心想，这大概是我能想象到的压力最大的一部分了，心想：哪怕我破产了也没关系。是的。好吧，有时候我真的觉得自己要崩溃了，我甚至用我的Monso账户来支付工资。就像，你知道的，有一次我们差一点就发不出工资了，我当时就想：操。结果我第二天就把车卖给了一个我在网上认识的人，那真的就像是个，那是什么来着？那就像是一个会直接上门把你车买走的回收服务。我当时就想，我都不知道这到底合不合法。
But it was like, as long as I bought the money in my account before they, before they leave, I was like, sounds like my solution for the week. So yeah, there have been like big, like big, terrible, like prolonged very life, um, ruining at the time kind of, um, things to go through. Um, and then there were the small ones every day. Like, there's, you know, the other day we had our, um, like, I hope we did. like a hotel, Tala. It was kind of like a... I saw it was so beautiful. Thank you.
但当时的想法是，只要他们在离开之前把钱转进我的账户就行了，我觉得这听起来就是我那周的解决方案。所以，是的，经历过很多重大的、糟糕的、持续很久的、在当时看来简直是毁灭性的时刻。然后就是每天都有的小烦恼。比如，前几天我们举办了我们的，呃，我希望我们办了，一个“Tala酒店”活动。那有点像是一个……我看到了，太美了。谢谢。
It was gorgeous. Thank you. It was essentially like a campaign that we did like what Tala would be like as a hotel and then hosted some people there. And, you know, even on the first day of that, like we sent two of our team members early to set everything up with like all of the stock and the decorations and like the cute little touches and everything. And five out of ten suitcases got lost and ended up like floating around Europe. And like the whole reason you send people early is that they can like set things up. It's just a little bit of chaos. Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, that type of stuff happens all the time. Same with I went out to New York Fashion Week. We were doing a New York Fashion Week activation and I was there for 48 hours before
真的太华丽了。谢谢。那基本上是一场我们策划的推广活动，展示如果Tala是一家酒店会是什么样子，然后我们在那里招待了一些人。而且，你知道，甚至在活动的第一天，我们派了两个团队成员提前过去，把所有的库存、装饰品、可爱的小摆设以及所有东西都布置好。结果十个行李箱里有五个居然弄丢了，最后在欧洲各地到处漂流。而你派人提前过去的全部原因就是为了让他们能把东西布置好。结果却是一团糟。是的。是的，所以，这种事情经常发生。就像我去参加纽约时装周一样，我们要在那里开展一场纽约时装周的活动，我在那里待了48小时，然后
I had to go somewhere else and I literally landed and my one suitcase that I had with me was lost and they were like, we can get it back to you in 48 hours and I was like, perfect. We've got our New York Fashion Week thing tomorrow. So it should be sooner. Yeah. Please and thank you. Have we considered teleporting? Yeah.
就得去别的地方了。我刚一落地，随身携带的唯一一个行李箱就丢了。他们说：“我们可以在48小时内把它送回给你。”我当时就说：“太完美了。我们明天就有纽约时装周的活动。”所以它应该早点到。对，拜托了谢谢。我们考虑过瞬间传送吗？对。
Did they pay you for that? I actually don't think I ended up getting any compensation. This is a random hill I die on, but airline compensation. It's so bad. I could start a business on it though. Oh yeah. I will always get compensation from airlines. Really?
他们为此赔偿你了吗？我其实觉得我最后什么赔偿都没拿到。这是一个我愿意为之死守的奇怪立场，但航空公司的赔偿政策真的太烂了。不过我其实可以为此开一家公司。哦，是的。我一定会从航空公司那里拿到赔偿的。真的吗？
Oh, I'm good at a sternly worded email around something like that. Oh no. I have beef with probably every airline bar one. I'm not going to go away. into them, bar one. And they sponsored the podcast and I love, that's the only reason. Oh my God, really? Yeah, literally. I had any, actually, I'll tell this story that I won't name names, but an airline who I had like the most despicable experience with, with my dad randomly, was like, we really want to sponsor the podcast and I was like, no. And my team was like, you really should do that. I was like, I would never. I would never stop my soul. Because I, yeah, anyways. Yeah, also then when I flew,
哦，我很擅长针对这种事写一封语气严厉的邮件。哦，天哪。除了其中一家之外，我和大概每一家航空公司都有过节。我不会深入细说，除了那一家。他们赞助了我的播客，我喜欢它，这就是唯一的理由。天哪，真的吗？对，千真万确。其实，我来讲个故事，虽然我不点名。有一家航空公司，我和我爸爸曾有过极其糟糕的经历。他们突然跑来跟我说：“我们真的很想赞助这个播客。”我直接说：“不要。”我的团队则对我说：“你真的应该接下这个。”我说：“我绝不。我永远不会出卖自己的灵魂。”因为我，好吧，总之。对，然后还有一次我坐飞机时，
to my next place. They literally, I was like, don't fly out to New York, keep it in London. I'll just get it when I'm back in London because I only need it for the next 48 hours. And then literally, as I flew off to the next place, it flew from London to New York. I was like, okay. I know. And it's so hard because it's like, I also will say I'm like, every single person who works for an airline, I'm like, I love you. Oh, yeah. I'm like, you guys do that probably a very hard job of like the only time people want to talk to you is when they're really mad. So it's always via email, but it's stuff like that where it's like their policies and it's like, policies just fuck them over. We need to fix this.
去我的下一个目的地。他们居然，我当时说：“别把行李空运到纽约去了，留在伦敦吧。等我回到伦敦自己去拿就行了，因为我接下来48小时只需要它。”然后，就在我飞往下一个目的地的时候，它居然从伦敦飞到了纽约。我当时就想：好吧。我知道。而且这太难了，因为我会对自己说，每一个在航空公司工作的人，我都觉得：我爱你们。哦，是的。我觉得你们的工作可能非常辛苦，因为人们只想在极其愤怒的时候才跟你们对话。所以这一切总是通过电子邮件解决，但就是这种事情，他们的规章制度，就像是那些政策把他们全坑惨了。我们需要解决这个问题。
We'll move on from airline politics. But that was my favorite problem of your question. Yeah, we can go on for ages. That's going to be our part two episode. Come back for the part two. Hey, I'm Rubikar, the host of the podcast, Encore. Check out our brand new episodes featuring music from the show that everyone is reheating as we speak. Heated rivalry. Join me as I go behind the songs that brought Shane and Elia together. I'll tell you, the stories of Fice, My Moon, My Man, Wolf Parades, I'll Believe in Anything, and tattoos all the things she said, and how they all became a part of this global phenomenon. Stream encore on IHeart Radio, crave, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们就不聊航空公司的那些事了。不过那是我最喜欢的一个关于你提问的问题。对，我们可以聊好久。这将会是我们的第二部分节目。欢迎回来收看第二部分。嘿，我是Rubikar，播客节目《安可》（Encore）的主持人。来看看我们的全新节目吧，其中包含每个人都在热议的剧集中的音乐。那就是《炽热竞争》（Heated rivalry）。加入我，一起深入探寻将肖恩（Shane）和埃利亚（Elia）紧紧联系在一起的那些歌曲背后的故事。我会告诉你，菲斯（Feist）的《我的月亮，我的男人》（My Moon, My Man）、狼群游行乐队（Wolf Parade）的《我会相信任何事》（I'll Believe in Anything），以及纹身乐队（tattoos）的《她所说的一切》（all the things she said）背后的故事，以及它们是如何成为这一全球现象的一部分的。在IHeart Radio、Crave或你获取播客的任何地方收听《安可》（Encore）。
What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and IHeart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these. days. The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments to take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. We'll give you our takes, our debates, and probably a few disagreements. We'll talk to athletes, celebrate big
最近怎么样，家人们？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯（Ari Chambers）。嘿，你们好吗？我是你们的女孩萨姆·J（Sam J）。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》（Everyone Watches Women's Sports）的主持人，这是一档来自Together和IHeart Women's Sports的全新播客。因为说实话。女子体育现在给我们提供了太多可以聊的话题。那些精彩集锦、宿敌对决、突然崭露头角的新星，以及那些霸占你整个时间线的精彩瞬间。还有那些从比赛期间开始，不知为何能整整讨论一整周的对话。每周我们都在剖析女子体育世界里最大的新闻。我们会分享我们的观点、辩论，可能还会有些许分歧。我们会与运动员对话，庆祝伟大的
moments and get into what's happening on and off the field, sport, track, and beyond. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. So if you're already a fan, or you're just getting into the game, there's a seat for you right here. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app,
时刻，并深入探讨场内场外、赛道内外的发生的一切，无论是体育运动还是其他领域。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们更对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。所以，无论你已经是它的忠实粉丝，还是刚刚开始接触这项运动，这里都为你留了一个座位。快来收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Munges shit together, and I'm back with a new season of the podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones, and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about. And what it really means to live for,
苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我是Munges shit together，我又带着播客节目《天际线大道》（Skyline Drive）的新一季回归了。这一次，我将深入探讨肽、类器官、换血疗法、长寿地区和大脑置换的无底洞，试图弄清楚这种对长寿的痴迷到底是关于什么的。以及对我们所有人来说，真正“永远”活下去意味着什么。
forever, for all of us. I learned about some rad science. I can make a brain for you, and then we can test what draw is the best for your brain, as opposed to his brain. Here are some hard truths. I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four-to-five-year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble.
我学到了一些很酷的科学知识。我可以为你制造一个大脑，然后我们可以测试哪种药物最适合你的大脑，而不是他的大脑。以下是一些残酷的真相。我原本预计印度人衰老的速度会更快，但我没想到会加速将近四到五年之久。这让我陷入了一个巨大的麻烦之中。
I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我想大概是开始“砸骨塑形”吧。这根本没用。为了让面部轮廓更立体。他们说这管用。我不知道。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《天际线大道：如何永生》（Skyline Drive How to Live Forever）。
Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The InHouse is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator, and host, and for years I've created a space where the un-housed and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Whedian Houses a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many
主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的残酷刻画，那些羞辱、指责并将无家可归者脸谱化的故事。《我们，无家可归者》（We The InHouse）是一档正在改变这一现状的播客。我是蒂奥·亨德森（Theo Henderson），创作者兼主持人，多年来我一直为无家可归者及他们的倡导者创造一个可以讲述他们自己故事的空间。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访过无家可归的父母、移民、守望相助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+社群，以及制定影响无家可归者生存状态的法律的政策制定者。《我们，无家可归者》是一档荣获威比奖（Webby）和信号奖（Signal Award）双料大奖的节目，未来还将迎来许多
exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill, which are a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community listen to wea and housed on the iHeart radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast this is michael rappaport and my podcast the i am rapaport's stereo podcast is unlike anyone you've ever heard or a variety show and if you're looking for strong opinions funny opinions about sports entertainment politics pop culture and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid, Jafar Jackson, is as good as Rami Malik as Freddie Mercury, and it's as good
令人兴奋的嘉宾。收听本周的节目，听我采访吉尔·库尔（Dr. Jill）博士，她是一位从街头医生转型为网红的医生，她在无家可归者社群中的工作在网上和她的社区里产生了巨大的影响。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我们，无家可归者》。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特（Michael Rappaport），我的播客《I Am Rapaport立体声播客》与你听过的任何人都不一样。我们是一个综合娱乐节目，如果你想听关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何能吸引我眼球的事物的犀利观点、有趣见解，现在就订阅吧。这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的小伙子，演迈克尔·杰克逊就像雷米·马利克演弗雷迪·墨古尔一样出色，也跟
as Timothy Chamalais as Bob Dylan. And I say that with love and respect for both of those actors. And I don't know how many Oscar nominations they give out, I don't know if it's five, six for best actor. 150% this kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively. get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
蒂莫西·柴勒梅德演鲍勃·迪伦一样精彩。我对这两位演员都充满爱与敬意。我不知道他们颁发多少个奥斯卡提名，我不知道是不是五、六个最佳男主角提名。150%可以肯定，这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的小伙子绝对应该因他饰演的迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。在I Heart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听I Am Rap Report。
You have such a natural talent for business. Have you ever been like, I'm done with that? And what do you think you'd do instead? Oh, so I'd say there have definitely been times where I've considered walking away. Not recently and not since I've kind of got my life balance a little bit more on track and therefore like moved away from burnout and um you know there are still little bits and times where I'm like for fuck sake but I do genuinely absolutely love what I do and I feel very privileged to be able to do what I do and also I've built my career I've like kind of reverse
你在商业方面有着如此天生的才华。你有没有过这种想法：“我受够了”？你觉得你如果不做这个会做什么呢？哦，所以我可以说，肯定有过那么一些时刻，我考虑过一走了之。不是最近，也不是自我把生活状态调整得稍微有些步入正轨、从而摆脱了精疲力竭的状态之后……而且，你知道的，仍然会有一些小瞬间和某些时刻我会忍不住爆粗口：“操他的。”但我真心实意地绝对热爱我所做的事情，并且为能做自己喜欢的事感到非常荣幸。此外，我还构建了我的职业生涯，我可以说，我逆向
engineered my career towards exactly what I want it to be like I kind of fell into being an influencer at the one point and then was like this is I do not like again massive privilege but it's like I do not like the day to day of this I do not like needing to to be liked in order for my career to be working like doing well. I do not like needing to show my personal life for my career to be doing well, all of these things. And so literally built myself an office job in the businesses. And like so I do think that I've like my job is made for me. Like it's very tailored to me. Um, which I feel very lucky for, for about because of, all of. There is luck involved. There, there'll be luck. Baby be lucky.
设计了自己的职业生涯，让它完全成为我想要的样子。我曾经在某一个时间点误打误撞成了一名网红，然后心想：这，我其实不喜欢。再说一次，这绝对是极大的特权，但我的意思是：我不喜欢这种日常生活，我不为了让职业生涯运转良好就必须去讨人喜欢。我不喜欢为了让职业生涯发展顺利而去展示我的个人生活，等等这些。所以，我实际上在这些企业里给自己建立了一份办公室工作。而且，因此我确实认为我的工作是为我而造的。它非常适合我。对此我感到非常幸运，因为这一切都包含着幸运的成分。这里面有运气的成分，确实会有运气。宝宝运气好。
Baby-luffy, yes, sometimes yes. But I think that the, you know, it absolutely takes it, it's tall. And I think that there have, you know, there have honestly been so many times where I'm like, what, why have I, like, why? Why did I need to make it so hard for myself? Just because, like, there's not really a reason to take it this far. Like, why four businesses? Why not one business?
宝宝很幸运，是的，有时确实如此。但我认为，你知道的，这绝对付出了代价。而且我觉得，你知道，真的有过很多次我都忍不住想：为什么我要？为什么我非要把自己搞得这么累？仅仅是因为，其实根本没有必要把事情推进到这种地步。为什么要创立四个公司？为什么不只经营一家公司？
You know, why, like, why did you need to do this? But I think realistically, as I've said, it's all built. for me and it's all been built around me. Like I've built it that way. And I feel very fortunate to, like I think one of the biggest privileges in life is being able to do work that you love and that you genuinely love because like everyone needs to work or most people need to work to be able to actually enjoy it and feel like you are day to day able to use your brain and kind of engage in the way you want to and be able to make my mind. from it. Like, I feel like that's very, very lucky.
你知道的，为什么，你为什么非要做这些？但我觉得现实情况是，正如我所说，这一切都是为我而建的，这一切都是围绕着我打造的。我是按照这种方式建立它的。而且我感到非常幸运，因为我认为人生中最大的特权之一就是能够从事你热爱的工作，并且是真正热爱的工作。因为每个人都需要工作，或者大多数人需要工作，才能真正享受生活，并且觉得自己在日常生活中能够运用自己的大脑，以自己想要的方式投入其中，并能从中赚取收入。我觉得这真的是极其、极其幸运。
It's such a good reminder as well. Yeah. And so yes and no, you'll probably find me some days where I'm like, yeah, absolutely, I need to get out of here. Back to the choir I go. Yeah, exactly. Broadway and I'm coming. Yeah. I like something that you mentioned before, which is, you know, you've spent your entire adult life online at this point. How do you keep parts of you just for you? You've obviously made a conscious decision about that in many ways. Yeah. So as I kind of alluded to then, I made a decision at one point to basically decide I was like, I'm not going to be an influencer, which you could absolutely still put me in that box now. I probably wouldn't though, to be honest. Thank you. I don't know. I think that like the
这也是一个很好的提醒。是的。所以，既是也不是，你可能有时会发现我情绪崩溃，然后说：“没错，绝对的，我得离开这里。”我还是回唱诗班去吧。对，完全如此。百老汇，我来啦。我喜欢你之前提到的一件事，那就是，你在此时此刻已经度过了你作为成年人的全部网络生活。你是如何把一部分自我只留给自己的？在很多方面，你显然对此做出了清醒的决定。是的。所以，正如我刚才所暗示的，我在某个时候做出了决定，基本上决定说：我不要当网红了。虽然你现在绝对还是可以把我归入那个范畴。不过老实说，我可能不会这么认为。谢谢。我不知道。我认为，
as a tangent, like the negative correlate, the negative kind of connotations of influencer is very much directly correlated to the fact that it is one of the only industries where women outperform. Oh yeah. And make more money than men and all of that. I don't think influencer is a bad term, but if it's not what your job title is. Yeah, no, no, of course. But as in like, I think that, like, I try and get comfortable with the fact that, like,
顺便说一句，作为题外话，网红这个词所带有的负面含义，在很大程度上直接与其作为女性表现出色的少数几个行业之一这一事实相关。哦，是的。而且女性赚的钱比男性多，诸如此类。我不认为“网红”是个贬义词，但如果这不是你的职业头衔的话。对，不，不，当然。但我的意思是，我认为，我试着去接受这样一个事实，即
technically it is what I'm doing and, you know, certain areas. And, like, probably the only reason we have these negative connotations around it is because women outperform in that area. And therefore, naturally, it's easy. It must be easy. It must not be worth anything. And it must be so easy and it must be all of these different things. Anyway, um, I, um, I,
从技术上讲，这就是我正在做的事情，在某些领域确实如此。而且，我们对这个词产生负面联想的唯一原因，可能只是因为女性在这个领域表现更出色。因此，很自然地，人们就会觉得这很容易。它一定很简单。它一定毫无价值。它肯定轻而易举，而且一定伴随着各种各样的偏见。不管怎样，我，
kind of decided that that wasn't for me in that I didn't enjoy the day to day, as I said. So I built myself, you know, I deleted all my videos off YouTube overnight and kind of that was where my main earnings were. I stopped really posting properly online
当时决定那不适合我，因为正如我所说，我并不享受这种日常生活。所以我为自己做了个决定，一夜之间删掉了YouTube上的所有视频，那是我主要的收入来源。我有一两年时间
for like two, three years. And concentrated on building businesses. I was like, I want to build these into what can actually sustain me and the team as a job. So doubled down on that. And I think that, that, you know, that has enabled me to be in the fortunate position where I don't need to share
没有真正在网上好好发过内容。而是专心建立公司。我当时想：我要把这些公司发展成能够真正维持我本人和团队生计的工作。所以我加倍投入其中。我认为，这（你知道的）使我处于一个幸运的地位，即我不需要为了赚取收入而分享
anything that I don't want to share in order to make income. And so I feel like I'm in the nice position now where I can share what I'd like to share and what I find would be helpful to share and feel happy doing so. And I feel much more happy doing so knowing that there is no obligation. Yeah. And so I think that actually has I don't know, probably in a weird way recently, like some people over the past few years have been like, oh, I think you're sharing more. And I was like, yeah, no, I probably am
任何我不想分享的东西。所以我觉得我现在处于一个很好的位置，可以分享我想分享的东西、我觉得会有所帮助的东西，并且在这样做时感到快乐。而且我怀着一种“没有任何强制义务”的心态去做这件事，这让我感到更加快乐。所以我觉得这实际上——我不知道，在过去几年里以一种奇怪的方式，有些人会说：“哦，我觉得你分享得更多了。”而我就会说：“是的，不，我可能确实分享得更多了。”
because I don't feel like backed against a wall in a way where I'm like, oh, God, I've got to give you this vulnerability so that you actually like me. Like, it's an exchange. Oh, yeah. And I don't want that. Like, I don't want to need to give you all of the five bad things that are happening in my life for you to give me basic human respect.
因为我不再觉得自己被逼入绝境，不会再觉得“天哪，我必须向你展现这种脆弱，你才会真正喜欢我”。这就像是一场交易。哦，是的。而我并不想要这样。我不想为了让你给予我基本的尊重，就必须把发生在我生活中的所有五件糟糕的事都向你倾盘托出。
Yeah. And so I think that I'm, I guess, in a happy place around that now. It's organic. With that in mind, there has been things that you have shared online that are very, very personal. And it's obviously come from an organic place for you to share it, including a miscarriage you had last year. Did you think about not sharing that? Yeah, absolutely. And I didn't share it for a good while after it happened not a good while, like a few months. Yeah, wow. And I think that I was driven by a few reasons for sharing it.
是的。所以我觉得，关于这一点，我现在大概处于一个快乐的状态。这一切都很自然。带着这种心态，你在网上分享过一些非常非常私人的事情。很明显，分享这些对你来说是很自然的行为，包括你去年遭遇的那次流产。你曾考虑过不分享这件事吗？是的，绝对考虑过。而且在事情发生后的很长一段时间里，我都没有分享——也不是很久，大概几个月吧。哦，哇。我觉得我分享这件事是出于几个原因的驱使。
I think that, like, one part of it was, like, definitely, and I wouldn't stand by this. This is a good reason for sharing. But I definitely, like, it was meant to be a really intense work month, and I still worked a lot. But I think that, like, I just hadn't been myself and hadn't, like, done things to the best of my ability that month. And so I kind of felt like I was like, oh, by the way, guys, this is why I've been so shit. But that wasn't the main reason for sharing. the main reason was more the fact that I found it so insane how there was so much taboo around it and how it was automatically like you're pregnant, yay, oh, you miscarried, oh, let's not talk about that.
我觉得，其中一部分原因肯定是——而且我不会为此辩解，这并不是分享的好理由——我当时确实觉得，那本该是一个工作强度非常大的月份，而且我确实也做了很多工作。但我认为，那一个月我整个人都不在状态，没有把事情做到我能力的极致。所以我当时有点想说：“哦，顺便说一句，各位，这就是为什么我最近表现得这么烂。”但这不是分享的主要原因。分享的主要原因更多是因为，我觉得这种现象太疯狂了：周围竟然存在着这么多的禁忌，并且人们会自动觉得“你怀孕了，太棒了；哦，你流产了，哦，我们别谈这个”。
Like, that is, the blame is on the woman, the kind of, I don't know, the onus for everything that's on the woman. The taboo is on them. They mostly can't tell their workplace because there's still loads of associations around it and they don't know if they're actually going to get the support and if that's just going to make them feel even shitter. and whether it's something that they even want to say because then their employer knows they're trying for a baby like all of these different things. And I kind of just wanted to talk about it because it was actually so fucking hard to go through
这就好像，把责任归咎于女性，把一切重担都压在女性身上。禁忌都指向她们。她们大多不能向工作单位倾诉，因为周围依然存在着大量的偏见，她们不知道自己是否真的能得到支持，也不知道这会不会让她们感觉更糟，甚至不知道这究竟是不是她们想说的话，因为一旦说了，老板就会知道她们在备孕——所有这些不同的事情。我当时只是想谈论它，因为经历这一切实在是太他妈艰难了。
that I just was like, I can't believe that this in any way is made to be, like, made out to be, not necessarily like my fault, but kind of like, we shouldn't talk about it, because it might embarrass other people or it might make people feel awkward. And I even had that from like some people quite close to me when I was like
我简直不敢相信，这件事在任何程度上都会被塑造成——倒不一定是我的错——但就好像我们不应该谈论它，因为这可能会让别人感到尴尬，或者让人觉得别扭。甚至当我跟一些关系相当亲密的人倾诉时，他们也给我这种感觉：
never even like saying the word or acknowledging the thing or even like asking how I was. Like it was very, you know? And I just thought, God, that's crazy. Like people for years and years, decades, haven't said anything about it ever. Because it's just a taboo subject. And I just thought, I don't like taboo subjects that are taboo and create. shame for the woman when there's no reason for it. And it's like this final frontier of grief almost that we are yet to really have any good language for speaking about. Like we don't have
甚至从来没有说出过那个词，或者承认过这件事，甚至连一句“你还好吗”都没有。非常……你知道吗？我当时想：天哪，这太疯狂了。多年来，几十年里，人们对此闭口不谈。仅仅因为它是一个禁忌话题。我当时就想：我讨厌那些制造禁忌、给女性带来羞耻感却又毫无理由的禁忌话题。而且这几乎是悲伤的最后一片前沿阵地，我们至今还没有找到任何好的语言来谈论它。就像我们没有
great language for talking about grief in other areas or mental health in other areas or anything. But for this one, it does feel like really you don't see anybody talk about it. Yeah. And that must have been really scary for you to step into and be like, if I don't see anybody talking about it, how are people going to react? Yeah, no, absolutely. And I think that I do believe that when you have a platform, you do actually have some sort of responsibility to, well, you have more propensity to make the world a place that you would want it to be.
很好的语言来谈论其他领域的悲伤，或者其他领域的心理健康一样。但对于这个话题，你真的看不到任何人去谈论它。是的。对于你来说，涉足这个领域一定非常吓人，你会想：如果我看不到任何人谈论它，大家会有什么反应？是的，完全如此。而且我相信，当你拥有一个平台时，你确实有某种责任去——或者说，你更有能力让这个世界变成你所期望的那个样子。
So you have a sort of responsibility to, okay, well, no, you don't need to share things that you don't want to share like that. I don't think is owed to the general public. But I do think that if you can do something to make the world a place, that's more reflective of the place that you'd want it to be, then, like, why not? And so, yeah, it was a decision at the time because I wanted to, I wanted it to be something where you can say that without, like, I felt like I couldn't even say it without, like, ruining someone else's day. And I was just like, I get that. But at the same time, like,
所以你有一种责任去……好吧，不，你不需要分享你不想分享的事情，那并不是你欠广大公众的。但我确实认为，如果你能做点什么让这个世界变得更符合你所期望的样子，那么，为什么不呢？所以，是的，当时这是一个决定，因为我想让它成为这样一件事：你可以把这件事说出来，而不用……我当时觉得我甚至无法开口，否则就会毁了别人的好心情。我当时就想：我理解这一点。但与此同时，
if I need to disclose this to you for some reason, I need to not go into overdrive of like, oh, I'm so sorry, but it's also fine. It's fine. You know, like, you don't get, you know, It's okay and it's like, that's really difficult. And every time you swallow it, it's like, I'm so worried about burdening this person one time. And it's like, and I burden myself every day. Yeah. Every single day. Were you worried about a particular kind of reaction?
如果出于某些原因我需要向你透露这件事，我不需要进入那种疯狂的状态，去说“哦，我真的很抱歉，不过也没关系。没关系。”你知道的，你不会得到……这没关系，而这真的很困难。每次你把话咽回去，就好像：我太担心给这个人带来一次负担了。然后就变成了：我每天都在给自己增加负担。是的。每天如此。你是否担心某种特定的反应？
Was there one that scared you the most that people might have? I think I, because it was so fresh in terms of like emotions. And I think it, you know, it will be for a long time. I think I was, I'm always worried about like the internet having like fuel with which to, you know, throw at you when is. desired. So like, for example, I did a post a few weeks later that was like talking about the risk of reform coming into power in the UK and the different impacts that would have on essentially society in like various different ways. And someone commented on that being like, you should be concentrating more on keeping your babies alive than talking about this,
有没有哪种反应是你最害怕人们会做出的？我想我当时是因为情绪还很新鲜。而且我觉得，在很长一段时间里它都会是新鲜的。我当时担心的是，互联网总是会寻找燃料，随时准备在需要的时候向你砸过来。比如，几周后我发了一条帖子，谈到英国改革党上台的风险，以及这基本上会以各种不同方式对社会产生的影响。有人在那条帖子下评论说：“你应该多花点精力让你的孩子活着，而不是谈论这个。”
which I'm laughing about. Obviously, it's an abhorrent comment. But it's also so outrageous that I was literally like, I literally saw it while having breakfast with my husband, and I literally like choked. And I was like, oh my God, you're not going to believe this. And I was just like, to be fair, as you can tell, like that type of thing doesn't really affect me because you've got to be so fucked up
我现在说起来都在笑。很显然，这是一个令人发指的评论。但它同时也荒谬到极致，当时我和我丈夫吃着早餐看到这条评论，我差点被噎住。我当时就想：“天哪，你绝对不敢相信这个。”我当时的想法是：说实话，正如你所见，这类事情其实并不会真正影响到我，因为能说出这种话的人脑子一定极其不正常。
for that to actually make it anywhere out of your keyboard, like for you to be pressing your brain cells. Even your brain, like, unless that's a violent, intrusive thought that you literally cannot keep under control, like the fact that you've now put, that onto paper and like got that out is just I have to feel so sorry for you because you must be so miserable and I know people say that it's like they must be miserable they must be miserable it's like I don't believe that all online commentary must be from people who are miserable but it's literally
要让它真正在你的键盘之外流传开来，比如让你耗费脑细胞。甚至你的大脑，除非那是一个你根本无法控制的暴力、侵入性的想法，否则你现在把它写在纸上并表达出来的这件事，我真的为你感到难过，因为你一定非常痛苦。我知道人们会说“他们一定很痛苦，他们一定很痛苦”，就好像我不相信所有的网络评论一定都来自痛苦的人，但它真的
like wow like wow you must be so hurt inside about like I don't know who didn't listen to you when yeah like wow I almost see that as like sociopathy no yeah I genuinely want this person I want to them in a little cage and we'll just, like, what's wrong with you? Yeah, literally. Let's have a look around. Like, that's, that's a, I actually, very few things leave me speechless. Oh, that was, I was, I was just like, what was your husband's reaction? Because yours was like, oh my God, was he just like, he was quite angry about it. He was like how, I think, I mean, he'd obviously gone through it as well. I think he'd, you know, seen me going through that and then was like, fucking hell. Like, that is terrible. But I thought it was so.
就像，哇，天哪，你的内心一定受到了多大的伤害，比如，我不知道是谁没有听你说话，以至于——是的，天哪，我甚至觉得这有点反社会倾向。不，是的，我真的希望这个人，我想把他们关在一个小笼子里，然后我们就会想，你脑子有毛病吧？是的，真的。让我们四处看看。这，这，我实际上，很少有什么事能让我无言以对。哦，那是，我当时就想，你丈夫的反应是什么？因为你的反应是，哦，天哪，他是不是觉得——他对此相当生气。他觉得怎么会，我想，我的意思是，他显然也经历过这些。我想他，你知道的，看着我经历那些，然后就觉得，他妈的。这太可怕了。但我当时觉得它
bad that I actually found it hilarious. Like, as in, like, I send it to some of my friends and I was like, oh, my God. And my friends were sending me paragraphs back. Like, this person is like, blah, blah, blah. And I was like, guys, I'm laughing. Yeah. As in like, I'm literally laughing. Because you can't go that.
太糟糕了，以至于我甚至觉得这很搞笑。比如，我把它发给我的一些朋友，然后我说，哦，天哪。我的朋友们发回了一大段话。就像，这个人是这样这样，诸如此类。然后我说，伙计们，我在笑。是的。也就是说，我真的在笑。因为你不能那样做。
It's a horseshoe. Like, come on. Yeah. So deranged. That is just like, you actually, like, you have more problems than I have if you are sending that message. Anonymous account? Probably.
这简直是个回力镖。拜托。太疯狂了。那就像，如果你发了那条信息，你其实比我更有问题。匿名账号？很可能。
Yeah. Probably like Psalms 13 in the diet. Yeah, literally. Love thy neighbor. sorry not to laugh at the end of what was a heavy conversation sorry in listening song voice shit
是的。大概像《诗篇》第13篇和节食指南。是的，真的。爱你的邻居。抱歉，在一段沉重的对话结束时不该笑的。抱歉，用听歌的声音说，该死。
done it again done it again something you're going to be thinking about yeah I know I'm going to go home and be like dang it sorry not to not to make you feel I just think that comment's crazy and you're expecting again now and I get so many questions about becoming a mother in your 20s I haven't had that experience yet
又来了，又来了，这是你会一直在想的事情。是的，我知道我要回家然后想，该死。抱歉，不是为了让你觉得——我只是觉得那个评论太疯狂了。你现在又要期待新的了，我收到了很多关于在20多岁时成为母亲的问题，我还没有过这种经历。
and I don't actually get to talk to many people who had. So what is surprising you most about that whole chapter in your life from finding out you were pregnant for the first time to now carrying your second child? I think what's been surprising me most generally is like how outrageous and varied and intense all the different symptoms of pregnancy are that are 100% kept under wraps for a reason. And I would have 100% still decided that I wanted a baby and that I wanted to be pregnant. But at the same time, like, the fine print is not clear. And I... I think we, like, again, it's like, our sex education for women is so terrible.
而且我实际上没有机会和许多有过这种经历的人交流。那么，从得知自己第一次怀孕到现在怀上第二个孩子，你生命中的这段经历中，最让你惊讶的是什么？我觉得最让我惊讶的是，怀孕的各种症状是如此离谱、多样且强烈，而这些症状百分之百都被隐瞒了，这是有原因的。而且我百分之百还是会决定要一个孩子，并且想要怀孕。但与此同时，那些细则并不明确。而且我……我觉得我们，再次强调，就像，我们针对女性的性教育太糟糕了。
Sorry, I'm not crying. It's acid reflux. I want more sex. The roller coaster. I want more sick. Like, the sex education for women and actually probably more for girls is like so, so terrible and so fixated on like, don't have sex, don't get pregnant. Like, okay, well, what about when we're talking about, like, if you choose to get pregnant,
抱歉，我不是在哭。这是胃酸倒流。我还想要更多的爱。真是个过山车。我还想吐。比如，针对女性的性教育，实际上可能更针对女孩的教育，是如此、如此糟糕，并且死死盯着诸如“不要发生性行为”、“不要怀孕”之类的事情。好吧，那么当我们谈论，比方说，如果你选择怀孕，
or you find yourself in a situation where you are pregnant, like what's actually happening, what are all the different symptoms? Like there are some fucked symptoms that are absolutely kept from you. Like, the, I think it's the average woman ended up with 3.1 decade teeth after pregnancy. What?
或者你发现自己处于怀孕的境地时，到底会发生什么？有哪些不同的有些极其糟糕的症状是绝对不让你知道的。比如，我认为平均每个女性在怀孕后会掉3.1颗牙齿。什么？
The baby just takes all the nutrients from you. Or your calcium, everything. Like everything from you. There's like all sort, like, your ab split in half. Sometimes they'll have to be surgically put back together. But like all of this, I honestly think I'm anti-PR for pregnancy. and I don't mean to be that way, because I do think that, like, if you would like to be pregnant, then hopefully you're able to get pregnant.
婴儿只是从你身上夺走所有的营养。或者你的钙，什么都有。就像从你身上夺走一切。还有各种各样的情况，比如你的腹肌裂成两半。有时它们必须通过手术缝合在一起。但所有这一切，我老实说，我是怀孕的反向宣传者。我不是故意要这样的，因为我确实认为，如果你想要怀孕，那么希望你能怀上。
I also do just think that it is presented to women as, A, a necessity, be a kind of, well, this is just the way it is. And mark my words, if the symptoms were on the other gendered foot, there would be better research, there would be better medication, there would be better management. all of these different things. There would probably be paid pregnancy leave, like all of these different things. I just think it's not been made clear. And I think that anyone who wants to have a child would still decide to do so. It's just that there is not a lot of well-spread educational information. So I'd say that's the biggest shock in case it's not clear by my general demeanor. It's like people will climb the mountain, but they should know what's on the mountain first. They're still wanting to get to the top. Like, I still would have done it. But at the same
我也只是觉得，它被呈现给女性时，A是一种必然，B是一种“嗯，事情就是这样”。记住我的话，如果这些症状发生在另一个性别身上，会有更好的研究，会有更好的药物，会有更好的管理，所有这些不同的事情。可能会有带薪产假，所有这些不同的事情。我只是觉得这没有被说清楚。而且我认为任何想要孩子的人仍然会决定这样做。只是没有多少广为流传的教育信息。所以我想这是最大的打击，以防从我的整体神态中看不出来。就像人们会去爬山，但他们应该先知道山上有什么。他们仍然想登顶。就像，我当时还是会这么做的。但与此同时
time, like, you don't need to be lying to me about, like, all the things I'm going to go through. And of course, that is somewhat our responsibility to find out. But at the same time, like, it's a major medical event that's essentially considered just, well, yeah, you're a girly pop. Yeah. Sorry, don't have any teeth anymore. Well, exactly. The baby took them. Yep. That's crazy. My boyfriend went to the movies the other day, and he came back and he was like, white-faced. he was like, do you know that women poop themselves when they give birth? And I was like, yeah, he goes, 75% of them do. Yeah.
，你不需要对我撒谎，隐瞒我要经历的所有事情。当然，这在某种程度上也是我们的责任去了解。但与此同时，这是一场重大的医疗事件，基本上被认为只是，“好吧，是的，你是个可爱的小女孩。是的。抱歉，你再也没有牙齿了。”嗯，确实如此。宝宝把它拿走了。是的。这太疯狂了。我男朋友前几天去看电影，他回来的时候脸色煞白。他说：“你知道女性在分娩时会大便吗？”我当时说：“知道啊。”他说：“75%的人都会这样。”是的。
And I was like, yeah, I know. And he was like, they need to tell more people about that. And I was like, that's what the ad was for. That's also the least of the problems. I was going to say, I know, he went on a whole Google page and I was like, and this is why that's important as well. Because often the burden is on you experiencing it as a mother. Women around you hearing those feeling scared.
然后我说：“对啊，我知道。”他说：“他们应该把这事告诉更多的人。”我说：“这就是那个广告的目的。”这也是最无关紧要的问题。我正想说，我知道，他翻遍了整个谷歌页面，然后我说，这就是为什么这也很重要。因为通常重担都落在我身上，作为母亲去经历。你身边的女性听到这些会感到害怕。
never like men, just knowing the woman's experience? Well, it's slightly tied to that. I was part to say read an article. I watched a TikTok, right, the other day? Thank you for your honesty. It was very, very interesting. And it was essentially about the research gap between men and women when it comes to parenting and why it creates default parenthood
从来不像男人那样，只是了解女性的经历？好吧，这跟那有点关系。我本来想说读了一篇文章。我前几天看了一个TikTok，对吧？谢谢你的坦诚。非常、非常有趣。它本质上是关于父母在育儿方面的男女研究差距，以及为什么它会造成默认育儿现象。
and why it creates, therefore, like, essentially the uneven society in which we operate where women are expected to take on a significant amount of unpaid labor in comparison to men, particularly when it comes to things like parenting, but also housework and all of this. And it was essentially just saying how like women, because pregnancy is happening to them, will take on the burden of education around birth, around pregnancy, around parenting, around like babies' health, all of these different things. And then they take on that burden. And that naturally isn't replicated in the men because pregnancy isn't happening to them.
以及为什么它因此造成，本质上是一个不平等的社会，在这个社会中，与男性相比，女性被期望承担大量的无偿劳动，特别是涉及育儿的事情，还有家务以及所有这些。它本质上只是在说，女性因为怀孕正在发生在她们身上，所以会承担关于分娩、怀孕、育儿、婴儿健康等各个方面的教育负担。然后她们承担了这份负担。而这在男性身上自然没有得到复制，因为怀孕没有发生在他们身上。
Like, ideally they would see it as such if their partner is pregnant, but it's actually not naturally the case. even I'd expect in some progressive relationships and therefore there is this research gap which means that by the time you have the baby the woman spends a lot of time educating the man and maybe correcting on certain things like oh you're meant to support the head
理想情况下，如果他们的伴侣怀孕了，他们会将其视为如此，但这实际上并非自然而然的情况。甚至我预计在一些进步的关系中也是如此，因此存在这种研究差距，这意味着当你生下孩子时，女性花了很多时间来教育男性，甚至纠正某些事情，比如，哦，你应该托住头部。
or you're meant to do this or like whatever it might be which results in the default parent becoming the mum despite the fact that you both had a baby at the same time and this obviously naturally then goes around in circles in terms of who does more parenting child care like all of these different things and I think that's so interesting again because it's like pregnancy is seen as a women's issue and it's not advertised thoroughly
或者你应该这样做，或者无论可能是什么，这导致默认的父母成为母亲，尽管你们俩同时拥有一个孩子。这显然自然而然地在谁做更多的育儿、儿童照料等所有这些事情上周而复始。我觉得这再次非常有趣，因为怀孕被视为一个女性的问题，而且无论如何，它根本没有被彻底宣传。
at all regardless. So what are we going to do about it? So what are we going to do about? Well, Grace is going to make some TikToks. That's what are we going to do about. Like, Grace is going to make everyone hear about it. I can't remember what that meme was, but it was like being the opposite of someone who suffers in silence. Like you will be forced to, or like, you know, quiet interest or all of that. Like, you will be forced to hear about what I'm interested in and what I'm reading about. Yeah. I'm afraid. I want men to make those TikToks as well. I feel like, I just think that would be just so valuable to be like, here's what I'm learning. I know. I want to find some. I like them. I like to repost them. Good on you. She's finding the good five. Yeah, exactly.
到底。所以我们要怎么做？所以我们要怎么做？好吧，格蕾丝要做一些TikTok。这就是我们要做的。就像，格蕾丝要让所有人都听到这件事。我不记得那个梗是什么了，但就像是做一个在沉默中受苦的人的对立面。就像你将被迫，或者像，你知道的，安静的兴趣或所有这些。就像，你将被迫听到我感兴趣的事情以及我正在阅读的内容。是的。我恐怕是。我希望男人们也制作这样的TikTok。我觉得，我只是觉得那会非常有价值，就像，这是我正在学习的内容。我懂的。我想找一些。我喜欢它们。我喜欢转发它们。干得好。她正在寻找那优秀的五个。是的，正好。
I'm Ruby Carr, the host of the podcast, Encore. Check out our brand new episodes featuring music from the show that everyone is reheating as we speak. Heated rivalry. Join me as I go behind the songs that brought Shane and Elia together. I'll tell you the stories of Fice, My moon my man, wolf parades, I'll believe in anything, and tattoos all the things she said, and how they all became a part of this global phenomenon. Stream encore on IHeart Radio, crave, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all? It's your girl, Sam J.
我是鲁比·卡尔，播客《安可》的主持人。来看看我们的全新剧集，其中包含每个人都在津津乐道的剧中的音乐。宿敌。加入我的行列，探索将肖恩和埃利亚拉在一起的歌曲背后的故事。我将讲述Fice的歌曲《My moon my man》、Wolf Parade的《I'll believe in anything》以及Tatu的《All the things she said》的故事，以及它们如何成为这一全球现象的一部分。在IHeart Radio、Crave或您获取播客的任何地方收听《安可》。最近怎么样，各位？我是体育记者阿里·查伯斯。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。
And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together in IHeart women's sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments to take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. We'll give you our takes, our debates, and probably a few disagreements. We'll talk to athletes, celebrate big moments and get into what's happening on and off the field, court, track, and beyond. Because we're not just interested in what happened.
我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是一档来自Together和IHeart女子体育的新播客。因为说实话。女子体育现在给我们提供了太多的话题。精彩集锦、宿敌对决、崭露头角的新星、那些占领你整个时间线的时刻。还有那些在比赛期间开始，并且不知何故持续了一整周的对话。每周我们都在剖析女子体育中最大的故事。我们会给出我们的看法、我们的辩论，可能还有一些分歧。我们会采访运动员，庆祝重大时刻，并深入探讨场上、场下、赛场、跑道等地方正在发生的事情。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。
We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. So if you're already a fan, or you're just getting into the game, there's a seat for you right here. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。所以，如果你已经是粉丝，或者你刚刚开始接触这项运动，这里有你的座位。收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。
I'm Munga shit together, and I'm back with a new season of the podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones, and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about. And what it really means to live forever. for all of us.
我是曼加·希特加特，我带着播客《天际线大道》的新一季回来了。这一次，我深入研究了肽、类器官、血液男孩、蓝色地带和大脑替代品的兔子洞，试图了解这种对长寿的痴迷究竟是怎么回事。以及对我们所有人来说，永远活着究竟意味着什么。
I learned about some rad science. I can make a brain for you, and then we can test what draw is the best for your brain, as opposed to his brain. Here are some hard truths. I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four-to-five-year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble.
我了解了一些很酷的科学。我可以为你制造一个大脑，然后我们可以测试哪种药物最适合你的大脑，而不是他的大脑。这里有一些严酷的真相。我原以为印度人老得更快，但我没想到会加速近四到五年。并让自己陷入了一堆麻烦中。
I'd say probably start bones smashing, That doesn't work. Make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app,
我想说大概可以开始骨骼重塑了。那不管用。让它看起来更立体。他们说管用。我不知道。收听《天际线大道：如何长生不老》，在IHeart Radio应用程序、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of The Un-Housed, stories that shame and blame and paint the Un-Housed as a monolith. We The Un-House is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson,
Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。主流媒体充满了对无家可归者的残酷描绘，这些故事充满羞耻和责备，将无家可归者描绘成铁板一块。《我们是无家可归者》是一档正在改变这一现状的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，
creator, and host. And for years, I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. William Houses a two-time webby and signal award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon.
创作者兼主持人。多年来，我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者可以讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+群体以及制定影响无家可归者生存的法律的决策者。《我们是无家可归者》是一档获得两次韦比奖和信号奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。
Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Wichor. A street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Wey and Housed on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast,
本周收听我对吉尔·威乔尔博士的采访。她是一位由街头医生转型为网红的人，她对无家可归者社区的工作在网上和她的社区产生了巨大的影响。在IHard Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我们是无家可归者》。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客，
the I Am Rapaport Stereo Podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard. We're a variety show, and if you're looking for strong opinions, funny opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson is as good as Rami Malik as Freddie Mercury,
《我叫拉帕波特立体声播客》，与你听过的任何人都不一样。我们是一个综艺节目，如果你正在寻找强烈的观点，关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化或其他任何引起我注意的事情的有趣观点，那么现在就订阅吧。这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的孩子和饰演弗雷迪·墨丘利的拉米·马利克一样优秀，
and it's as good as Timothy Chamalais as Bob Dylan. And I say that with love and respect for both of those actors. And I don't know how many Oscar nominations they give out, I don't know if it's five, six for best actor. 150% this kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I am Rapaport podcast. I have two more questions for you about motherhood and then one more question. So that's three.
而且和饰演鲍勃·迪伦的蒂莫西·柴勒梅德一样优秀。我这样说，是对这两位演员的爱与尊重。我不知道他们会颁发多少个奥斯卡提名，我不知道是五个还是六个最佳男主角。150%这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的孩子绝对、肯定应该因为他饰演迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我叫拉帕波特》。我是拉帕波特播客。我还有两个关于母职的问题给你，然后还有一个问题。所以一共是三个。
Three more questions. You're good about it. I know. Thank you. Another thing on my resume. You're having a girl. What are you most excited to do with her? I don't know.
还有三个问题。你心态很好。我知道。谢谢。我简历上的又一项。你要生个女孩。你最兴奋和她一起做的事是什么？我不知道。
I think one of my biggest life aims. And I think this maybe surprises people because I think we do group particularly women into boxes. You're like, you're a career woman or you're like a mumsy woman or you're like this. But like my biggest like aim in life is to have a close-knit loving family. Like that is just like my driving force and I feel very excited about the opportunity of building that with my husband and building it to be exactly what we have hoped. And I have no doubt that it's going to be very, you know, there are going to be many things that don't go to plan. But at the same time, like, I just can't wait. Like I can't wait for my life to get a bit smaller for a while.
我认为我人生最大的目标之一。我想这可能会让人们感到惊讶，因为我认为我们尤其把女性归入各种框框。你会觉得，你是一个职业女性，或者你是一个充满母性的女性，或者你是这样的。但就像我人生最大的目标是拥有一个紧密团结、充满爱的家庭。就像这只是我的动力，我对与我丈夫建立这个家庭并将其建设成我们所希望的样子的机会感到非常兴奋。我毫不怀疑它会非常，你知道的，会有很多事情不按计划进行。但与此同时，就像，我简直迫不及待。就像我迫不及待地想让我的生活在一段时间内变得稍微小一点。
I really, I think I've concentrated for a very long time on not making my life as big as possible, because that's not been the driving force, but like reaching everything I want to reach in life and like kind of really working so hard to get there. And of course I'll continue to do so. Like I feel very strongly about being very open about the fact that I will be going back to working full time. And I think that it's insane that anyone who would know me or see what I've done be, surprised at the fact that I will have child care or the fact that I will, you know, be working on any of these things. But I just think that like, I really can't wait for the concentration just to be a little bit simpler. And like I just know, like, all I care about generally is as much as, you know,
我真的，我想我很长一段时间都专注于不让我的生活尽可能地变大，因为那不是动力，而是达到我在生活中想要达到的每一个目标，并且为了到达那里而努力工作。当然，我会继续这样做。我强烈地认为，对于我将重返全职工作这一事实，我应该非常坦诚。而且我认为，任何认识我或看到我所做过的事情的人，如果对我会有儿童保育服务，或者我会，你知道的，致力于这些事情中的任何一件感到惊讶，那简直是疯了。但我只是觉得，我真的迫不及待地想让专注点变得简单一点。而且我只是知道，我一般只关心，只要，你知道的，
I care about work and all of this. Like, that's kind of one side. The main things I care about are like relationships and the people around me. And I just can't wait to. build our little. Oh, little family. I actually saw this quote from Steve Kroll, I think you'll love, which is he was talking about how when he had a kid, he was like, everything in my professional life got easier. Because speaking of failure, he was like, I didn't care if they didn't like me or if I failed because I had all this to grow home to.
我关心工作和所有这些。就像，那是其中一方面。我关心主要事情是人际关系和周围的人。我简直迫不及待地想。建立我们的小家庭。哦，小家庭。我实际上看到了史蒂夫·科尔的一段话，我想你会喜欢的，他说的是当他有了孩子后，他说，我职业生活中的一切都变得更轻松了。因为说到失败，他说，我不在乎他们是否不喜欢我或者我是否失败了，因为我有所有这些可以回家面对的人。
Oh my God, I'm so excited for you. I want to finish the episode with this question, which is, what is one piece of advice you have for people in their 20s? that we haven't spoken about today. So much. There's so much I want to say. Can I split them up? You can do as many as you want.
哦，天哪，我为你感到兴奋。我想用这个问题来结束本集，那就是，对于20多岁的人，你有什么建议？这是我们今天还没有谈到的。太多了。我想说的话太多了。我可以把它们分开吗？你想说多少就说多少。
I feel like you are a treasure for an hour. So we're going to start part two now. Okay, career-wise, I think that there's a lot of focus right now on getting as far as you can in your 20s and being as big as you can in whatever sense that might be. So, for example, if it is impressive in your industry to be freelance rather than to be within a company, there's such a rush to get there. There's such a rush to like get those accolades or establish those things that make you be taken more seriously. I honestly could not recommend enough and I wish I'd done more of this. Learning as much as you can on employers' money. Like upskilling, trying new jobs, working in different types of teams, talking to as many. people as possible about their jobs. Like, your career is much longer than it's made out to be on TikTok. And that's not me kind of patronising and saying like you, but like that is a lot of the
我觉得你这一个小时简直是个宝藏。所以我们现在开始第二部分。好的，在职业方面，我认为现在人们非常关注在20多岁时尽可能走得远，并在任何意义上尽可能变得强大。因此，例如，如果在你的行业中，做自由职业者而不是在公司内部工作会给人留下深刻印象，那么就会有一股冲劲去实现这一点。有一种冲劲去获得那些荣誉或确立那些让你受到更认真对待的事情。老实说，我强烈推荐——我希望我能早点做更多这样的事。利用雇主的钱尽可能多地学习。比如提升技能、尝试新工作、在不同类型的团队中工作、与尽可能多的人交流
media we're consuming and we're seeing, you know, success looks like this at 30. Your career is going to be a hell of a lot longer than 30. And if you want to enjoy it and have longevity and all of that, the more you can do to truly learn as much as possible and to put yourself in. And to put yourself in, like what about imagining an amazing life at 40, 50, 60? That might not be about working all the time, but how are you going to get there? Is it going to be jumping ship at 23 when actually you don't know enough to do that? No, I believe so strongly that we're,
关于他们的工作。就像，你的职业生涯比你在TikTok上看到的要长得多。这并不是我在居高临下地说“你”，但这就是我们消费的很多媒体，我们看到的是，30岁时成功看起来是这样的。你的职业生涯要比30岁长得多。如果你想享受它并拥有长寿等等，你能做的越多，真正尽可能多地去学习并让自己投入其中。并让自己投入其中，比如想象一下40岁、50岁、60岁时精彩的生活？那可能不是关于一直工作，但你将如何到达那里？是在23岁时跳槽吗，而实际上你根本不知道怎么做？不，我坚信，
it's very glamourized online to sell a certain dream around a certain type of career and actually the best careers are built over time based on accumulating expertise and contacts and network overall. and skills and passions. And so focus on that rather than like a big shiny title or a big move to freelance rather than employed or whatever it might be for your industry. I think that's very important career side
网上将其浪漫化，以围绕某种类型的职业兜售某种梦想，而实际上最好的职业是随着时间的推移，在积累专业知识、人脉、整体网络以及技能和激情的基石上建立起来的。所以把重点放在那上面，而不是一个闪亮的大头衔，或者从受雇变成自由职业的大动作，或者无论对你的行业来说可能是什么。我认为这在职业方面非常重要，
and I think that's often missed. Then on the other side, general life, I just think that I don't let anyone make you feel like you're behind. Again, we have such a focus on like 30 under 30, you know, your life ending then, like all of this, I'm so fucking excited to turn 30. Like, there's so much I'm looking forward to that I just, like, I think this 20s is like a hot pot of kind of just being thrown in there and be like, achieve as much as possible and like find out who you are and like make some friends and falling up and get married and
而且这经常被忽视。然后另一方面，普通生活，我只是觉得，不要让任何人让你觉得自己落后了。同样，我们太专注于30岁之前取得30项成就，你知道，你的生活在那时就结束了，所有这些，我他妈的太高兴快要30岁了。就像，有很多我期待的事情，我只是觉得，这20多岁就像是一个大熔炉，被扔进去然后说，尽可能多地成就一番事业，弄清楚你是谁，结交一些朋友，坠入爱河并结婚，
have a baby and like all of these different things. And it's just like, again, life is long, hopefully. And like, you're just at the beginning of it. Like, don't let other people's need to rush make you rush. Because I think as well that we have like this warped perception of time. And if you're aiming to do X, Y, Z by 30, then, okay, you get to 30 and then what? Like, what happens then? Don't give yourself that like Olympic gold medal syndrome where you're working towards all these things or you're like just staying in a relationship because you don't want to be single at 30.
生个孩子，所有这些不同的事情。这就好像，人生还很漫长，希望如此。而且你才刚刚开始。不要让别人的急躁需求让你也变得急躁。因为我也认为我们对时间有一种扭曲的看法。如果你的目标是在30岁之前完成X、Y、Z，那么，好吧，你到了30岁然后呢？然后会发生什么？不要给自己那种奥运金牌综合症，为了所有这些事情而努力，或者仅仅因为你不想在30岁时单身而留在一段关系中。
And then you get to 30. Okay, now what? You're pushing for another year and another year and another year. You're only at 34. So, like, as in like, start thinking long term. and start thinking about what you actually enjoy and what you want your life to look like rather than what you want other people to perceive it as. Oh, I love that advice.
然后你到了30岁。好吧，现在怎么办？你在为又一年、又一年、又一年而奋斗。你才34岁。所以，就像，开始做长远打算。开始考虑你真正喜欢什么，以及你希望你的生活是什么样子，而不是你希望别人怎么看待它。哦，我喜欢这个建议。
Thank you. Especially as somebody whose career is dead at 30. Psychology of your 20s. Oh, my God. What are we going to do? What have you done? I know, I really screwed the preach on that one. Thank you so much for such wonderful, wonderful advice and such wonderful candor.
谢谢。特别是作为一个在30岁时职业生涯就结束的人。20多岁的心理学。哦，天哪。我们该怎么办？你做了什么？我知道，我刚才那番话真是说教味十足。非常感谢你提出如此精彩、美妙的建议和如此精彩的坦诚。
You're genuinely just a delightful person to talk to. Oh, thank you so much. That's very kind. As are you. Thanks, girl. I honestly think that when people have a sudden, I'm going to give you one more compliment. Are you ready? Yeah, yeah.
你真的是一个非常讨人喜欢的人，跟你聊天很愉快。哦，太感谢了。你太客气了。你也是。谢谢，女孩。我老实说，当人们突然，我要再给你一个赞美。准备好了吗？对，对。
Then you can go out. I really do think that you see somebody online and you're like, oh, they seem really nice. And there's always, I don't have this feeling, but there's always a thing of like, I wonder if they're like that in real life. And it's like, you are somebody I can say for people listening who are a fan of grace, like 100% like that, if not better in person. You just have such, you just exude such a brilliance. So I appreciate you coming on the psychology of your 20s.
然后你就可以出去了。我真的觉得你在网上看到某个人，然后你会想，哦，他们看起来真的很好。总会有那种感觉，我没有这种感觉，但总会有一种想法，就是不知道他们在现实生活中是不是也这样。就像，你是一个我可以对那些喜欢格蕾丝的听众说的人，在现实生活中100%就是这样，甚至更好。你身上散发着一种光芒。所以感谢你来到《20多岁的心理学》。
Thank you for having me. You and the baby. Me and the baby. The first baby on the podcast. What do you have to say for yourself? Just acid reflux. I'm going to leave everything in the description where to listen to working hard, where to buy a piece of Tala's workout gear.
谢谢你邀请我。你和宝宝。我和宝宝。播客上的第一个宝宝。你有什么要对大家说的吗？只有胃酸倒流。我会把所有信息留在简介里，去哪里听《Working Hard》，去哪里买Tala的运动装备。
I honestly swear by it. Your cinch singlet tops. Oh, yeah. That's so amazing. I have like three colors, brown, black, blue, if you want to buy my wardrobe. I will leave. Shout my wardrobe. And yeah, everything else that we can find you at.
我真的极力推荐。你们的紧身背心。哦，是的。太棒了。我有三种颜色，棕色、黑色、蓝色，如果你想买我的衣柜的话。我会留下。展示我的衣柜。还有，是的，所有其他能找到你的地方。
As always, guys, thank you for listening. If you've made it this far, leave a little baby emoji in the Spotify comments down below to wish grace. Congratulations and good luck on her, on entering motherhood. Impending birth. I know. I didn't want to be like, on impending birth. And as always, you can also watch episodes like this on Netflix. You can follow us on Instagram, substack.
一如既往，伙计们，谢谢你们的收听。如果你听到了这里，请在下方Spotify的评论区留下一个婴儿的表情符号，祝贺格蕾丝并祝她好运，即将迎来母职。即将分娩。我知道。我本来不想说“即将分娩”的。一如既往，你也可以在Netflix上观看这样的剧集。你可以在Instagram、Substack上关注我们。
It's all going to be down there. But until next time, be safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO rewatch,
一切都会在下面。但直到下次，注意安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，波特兰迪亚的粉丝们。我是凯莉·布朗斯坦和弗雷德·阿米森。90年代的梦想在播客形式中依然活着。我们正在推出《波特兰迪亚重温》，
our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more.
这是我们的全新播客，我们将一起重温《波特兰迪亚》的每一集，剖析小品，深入探讨我们的标志性角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将有帮助将其变为现实的人们加入我们。明星嘉宾、合作者和朋友，包括导演乔纳森·克里塞尔、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、传奇音乐家艾米·曼等等。
Kyle is going. going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you're all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. rewatch starting July 16th on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Mangishatigula, and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I talked to scientists, biopunks, curmudgins, blues owners, super seniors, and Goa's top cryotherapy lab to try to understand this. obsession with living forever and what it means for all of us. And I get into a bit of trouble along the way.
凯尔要全力以赴了。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为你们都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听《波特兰迪亚：重温》，7月16日开始，在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。我是曼加·希蒂古拉，我带着我的播客《天际线大道》的新一季回来了。这一次我采访了科学家、生物朋克、脾气暴躁的人、蓝色地带居民、超级老年人和果阿顶级冷冻疗法实验室，试图了解这种对长寿的痴迷，以及它对我们所有人的意义。一路上我也惹上了一些麻烦。
I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. Make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rapaport Stereo Podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard.
我想说大概可以开始骨骼重塑了。那不管用。让它看起来更立体。他们说管用。我不知道。收听《天际线大道：如何长生不老》，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客，《我叫拉帕波特立体声播客》，与你听过的任何人都不一样。
If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. For years, the Unhouse has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created this show why I was unhoused on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares unhoused stories and news from the unhoused perspective.
如果你正在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及其他任何引起我注意的事情的强烈观点，那么现在就订阅吧。这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的孩子绝对、肯定应该因为他饰演迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我叫拉帕波特》。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为铁板一块。《我们是无家可归者》是一档正在改变这一叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创立了这个节目。我们已经成长为一个获得两次韦比奖的播客，也是唯一一个从无家可归者的角度分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。
Listen to Wey and Housed on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. We've all been there. We've had seasons that have shaken everything. The question is, what remains? remains when the shaking stops. Hi, I'm Gary Valenzheno. And on my podcast, Unshaken with Gary Vee, I sit down with amazing personalities and we talk about the seasons that nearly broke them,
在IHard Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我们是无家可归者》。我们都经历过那样的时期。我们经历过动摇一切的季节。问题是，当动摇停止时，还剩下什么？嗨，我是加里·瓦伦泽诺。在我的播客《与加里·维一起坚定不移》中，我与优秀的个性人物坐在一起，我们谈论那些几乎击垮他们的季节，
the lows that carried them to their highs. Listen to Unshaken with Gary Vee on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那些将他们带向高峰的低谷。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《与加里·维一起坚定不移》。这是一个IHeart播客。人类保证。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。